El Museo Picasso Málaga presenta Picasso es cultor, al igual que en el resto de su creación, la escultura de Picasso se distingue por innovar en el uso de técnicas y materiales pocortodoxos. Puedes imaginar cuáles y como, descubrela. Our episodes deal with serious and often-distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The names of several witnesses in this case have been changed.
马拉加毕加索博物馆呈现“毕加索是雕塑家”，正如他其他创作领域一样，毕加索的雕塑以创新使用非正统技术和材料而著称。你能想象出是哪些材料以及如何使用吗？快来一探究竟。我们的剧集涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。本案中几位证人的姓名已作更改。
Melbourne resident Irene Langley was looking through the heraldson newspaper when she came across a job ad for phone sex workers. The customer would ring a 1900 number and he pre-recorded messages from various women. When they heard one they liked, they dial a pin number that directed the call to that particular person. Irene took on the job and had the calls come through to her home phone. After a year in the role, only three calls left her feeling disturbed. One customer told Irene that he'd become sexually aroused while watching his sister shower. Another
墨尔本居民艾琳·兰利在翻阅《先驱太阳报》时，偶然看到一则招聘电话性工作者的广告。客户会拨打一个1900开头的号码，收听几位女性预先录制的信息。当他们听到喜欢的录音时，会拨打一个PIN码，将电话转接到该特定人员。艾琳接下了这份工作，并将电话转接到她家里的座机上。在从事该职位的这一年里，只有三个电话让她感到不安。一位客户告诉艾琳，他在看他姐姐洗澡时产生了性冲动。另一位
expressed a desire to have sex with his own daughter. The third man wanted to speak to an older woman. To appease him, Irene pretended she was 55 years old. In a mean, angry voice, the caller asked, Do you know what I did to the bitch? When Irene asked who, the man responded, My mother, the bitch. He said he'd pressed his hand on her neck before cutting across one of her breasts and slicing through her nipple.
表达了想与自己女儿发生性关系的欲望。第三名男子想与一位年长的女性交谈。为了安抚他，艾琳谎称自己55岁。电话那头的男子用一种刻薄、愤怒的声音问道：“你知道我对那个婊子做了什么吗？”当艾琳问是谁时，那名男子回答：“我母亲，那个婊子。”他说他曾用手按住她的脖子，然后割开了她的一侧乳房，并切断了她的乳头。
As the man spoke of the blood, his voice became animated and his breathing increased, as though he were aroused. How does that make you feel, he asked. Horrified, Irene ended the call. The man called back shortly after, warning. Listen, don't hang up. I know where you live and who you are. Again, he started talking about attacking a woman, his tone low and hateful.
当那名男子谈论鲜血时，他的声音变得兴奋，呼吸也变得急促，仿佛他很兴奋。“这让你感觉如何？”他问道。艾琳感到恐惧，挂断了电话。不久后，那名男子又打了回来，警告道：“听着，别挂电话。我知道你住在哪里，也知道你是谁。”他又开始谈论袭击一名女性，语气低沉而充满仇恨。
Irene listened in stunned fear, struggling to take in what the caller was saying. He said he looked into the woman's eyes as he put the steel down her stomach. He didn't say knife specifically, but Irene knew that's what he meant. He didn't say Knife specifically, but Irene knew that's what he meant. She tried to interrupt, but it only made the man angry. He mentioned the blood again, how it had seeped out of the cut nipple and it got on him. He then spoke of, quote, fucking the woman with the blade. Irene could hear his excitement growing and believed he was now masturbating. His description of the mutilation was so vivid, Irene could picture the woman
艾琳惊恐地听着，努力消化对方所说的话。他说他把钢刀刺入她腹部时，看着她的眼睛。他没有具体说“刀”，但艾琳知道他指的就是那个。他没有具体说“刀”，但艾琳知道他指的就是那个。她试图打断他，但这只会让那名男子更加愤怒。他又提到了血，说血从被割下的乳头上渗出来，溅到了他身上。随后他谈到了，引用他的话，“用刀刃强奸”那名女性。艾琳能感觉到他的兴奋感在增强，并相信他当时正在自慰。他对残害过程的描述如此生动，以至于艾琳能想象出那名女性
as a real person. She called him a sick prick and hung up. Irene waited, then picked up the receiver again. The men were still there. Old Kant, he barked, before Irene swiftly pulled the phone's cord from the wall. It was a little after 1pm on Saturday, October 4, 1997, when pensioners Ronald and Immuriel McDonald drove down Clifford's road. The unsealed back road framed the Craigie-Burn railway line on the industrial outskirts of Summerton, a suburb 21km north of Melbourne. The area drew little traffic and was used as an illegal dump site for hard rubbish. The McDonald's often took Clifford's road on their route home, keeping an eye out for any new junk piles to rummage through. Sometimes they
是一个真实的人。她骂他是个变态，然后挂断了电话。艾琳等了一会儿，又拿起听筒。那名男子还在那里。“老混蛋，”他咆哮道，随后艾琳迅速拔掉了墙上的电话线。那是1997年10月4日星期六下午1点多，养老金领取者罗纳德和穆里尔·麦克唐纳夫妇开车沿着克利福德路行驶。这条未铺设的后路环绕着克雷吉本铁路线，位于墨尔本以北21公里处的萨默顿工业郊区。该地区人烟稀少，被用作非法倾倒建筑垃圾的场所。麦克唐纳夫妇经常走克利福德路回家，留意是否有新的垃圾堆可以翻找。有时他们
don't cover something worth selling. The couple were joined that day by Muriel's sister, Elaine. The couple were joined that day by Muriel's sister, Elaine. The trio spotted an assortment of computer parts and boxes discarded among the overgrown grass and pulled over to examine the pile. Ronald lived at a sheet of cardboard and exclaimed, oh, what's that? He could see a hint and part of a leg. Muriel thought her husband had exposed a storm Anakin. I don't think so, Ronald replied. He observed rings on the fingers, a bracelet on the wrist, and a tattoo on the leg.
会发现一些值得卖钱的东西。那天，穆里尔的妹妹伊莱恩也和这对夫妇在一起。那天，穆里尔的妹妹伊莱恩也和这对夫妇在一起。三人发现杂草丛中丢弃着各种电脑零件和盒子，于是停下车检查那堆东西。罗纳德掀开一块纸板，惊呼道：“哦，那是什么？”他能看到一点东西和一条腿。穆里尔以为她丈夫发现了一个人体模型。“我不这么认为，”罗纳德回答。他观察到手指上有戒指，手腕上有手镯，腿上还有纹身。
He knew it was a human body. Ronald returned to his car where he had a phone fitted and called the police. Officers arrived and identified the body as a middle aged woman with bleached blonde hair. Her pants and underwear had been pulled down and her blouse and top were pushed up. A large wound was visible on the left side of her chest. There was also
他知道那是一具人体。罗纳德回到车里，那里装有电话，他报了警。警察赶到现场，确认死者是一名染着金发的中年女性。她的裤子和内衣被拉下，衬衫和上衣被推上去。她的左胸部可见一处巨大的伤口。还有
something poking out of the woman's lips. It was a nipple. Her left breast had been removed and stuffed into her mouth. The victim was known to authorities and welfare services. She was 40-year-old Margaret Ma from the neighboring suburb of Craigieburn. Margaret typically lived alone, but her teenage daughter had been staying with her as they endeavoured to bridge a gap that had formed between them. Margaret had lived an ordinary life as a bank worker until she was introduced to heroin. By October 1997, she was a recovering long-term drug user and sex worker. An autopsy concluded that Margaret had been killed elsewhere, then dumped on the side of
有什么东西从那名女性的嘴唇里伸出来。那是乳头。她的左乳房被切除并塞进了嘴里。受害者是当局和福利机构的熟人。她是来自邻近郊区克雷吉本的40岁女性玛格丽特·马。玛格丽特通常独居，但她十几岁的女儿一直和她住在一起，因为她们试图弥合两人之间产生的隔阂。玛格丽特曾是一名银行职员，过着平凡的生活，直到她接触了海洛因。到1997年10月，她是一名正在康复的长期吸毒者和性工作者。尸检结论显示，玛格丽特是在别处被杀害，然后被抛弃在
Clifford's road in the early hours of the day she was found. She had bruising and stub wounds across her neck, abdomen and limbs, and had sustained a severe blow to the upper right side of her head. Her left wrist had a particularly deep incision, and her neck featured evidence of compression, though her exact cause of death couldn't be ascertained. Margaret's left breast had been mutilated post-mortem by a knife used in a ragged soaring motion. A timeline of her final movements was pieced together. Margaret left home at 7 on the night of Friday, October 3 to visit a local news agency. By the time she returned home, her daughter had gone out and taken the house keys with her,
克利福德路边，时间是在她被发现当天的凌晨。她的脖子、腹部和四肢有淤青和刺伤，头部右上方受到重击。她的左手腕有一处特别深的切口，脖子上有受压的痕迹，尽管无法确定她的确切死因。玛格丽特的左乳房是在死后被一把刀以粗糙的锯割动作残害的。她最后行踪的时间线被拼凑了出来。玛格丽特于10月3日星期五晚上7点离开家去访问当地的一家报刊代理处。当她回到家时，她女儿已经出门并带走了房门钥匙，
leaving Margaret locked out. She asked a neighbor for help, but they didn't have the tools needed to get into her house. At around 7.45pm, Margaret was sighted hitchhiking on the nearby Hume Highway. This wasn't unusual as Margaret often relied on her tracking to get around. At 805, she was spotted entering a pharmacy in the nearby suburb of Strathmore, where she bought medication. She then got herself several kilometers north to a shopping complex in broadmeadows. Margaret was a familiar face in the supermarket there and was seen by staff browsing the health, beauty and hygiene aisles before paying for several items. At around midnight, a woman saw Margaret walking through the complex's car park carrying
导致玛格丽特被锁在门外。她向邻居求助，但他们没有进入她家所需的工具。晚上7点45分左右，有人看到玛格丽特在附近的休姆高速公路上搭便车。这并不罕见，因为玛格丽特经常依靠搭便车出行。8点05分，她被发现进入了附近斯特拉斯莫尔郊区的一家药店，在那里她买了药。然后她自己去了几公里外布罗德梅多斯的一个购物中心。玛格丽特是那里超市的熟面孔，工作人员看到她在健康、美容和卫生用品区浏览，然后支付了几件商品。午夜左右，一名女性看到玛格丽特带着
several shopping bags. She wasn't seen again. It was likely that Margaret crossed paths with her killer as she hitchhiked to each destination. A single black woolen glove found alongside Margaret's body was thought to be the key to solving her murder. It was tested, but limitations in forensic technology prevented any significant discoveries. A 15-minute drive south from where Margaret Mars' body was found is the expansive and serene grounds of Faulkner's cemetery. In the month following Margaret's murder, a woman named Janet Morton visited Faulkner's cemetery to research her family tree.
几个购物袋走过购物中心的停车场。之后她就再也没有出现过。玛格丽特很可能是在搭便车前往每个目的地时与凶手相遇的。在玛格丽特·马的尸体旁发现的一只黑色羊毛手套被认为是破获她谋杀案的关键。它经过了测试，但法医技术的局限性阻碍了任何重大发现。从发现玛格丽特·马尸体的地方向南开车15分钟，就是广阔而宁静的福克纳公墓。在玛格丽特被谋杀后的一个月里，一位名叫珍妮特·莫顿的女性访问了福克纳公墓，研究她的家谱。
Janet stood alone in a rose garden examining plaques when she glanced up and noticed the middle aged men on the opposite side of the flower bed. He was short and overweight, with thin, light-colored hair styled in a bowl cart. Janet smiled at the unassuming man, but he ignored her. Janet went to another section where she soon spotted the man again. She then headed to an area 50 feet away, only to realise the man had seemingly followed her there, too. Janet glanced over and met his gaze, realizing then that he'd been watching her. Janet moved on to an older area of the cemetery where she intended to find two particular graves. Her attention was cast downward as she scanned the headstones, when suddenly she heard something to her left.
珍妮特独自站在玫瑰园里检查牌匾，这时她抬头注意到花坛对面有一名中年男子。他个子矮小，超重，留着稀疏的浅色头发，发型是锅盖头。珍妮特对这个不起眼的男人笑了笑，但他没有理会她。珍妮特去了另一个区域，很快又看到了那个男人。她随后前往50英尺外的一个区域，却意识到那个男人似乎也跟着她到了那里。珍妮特抬头与他对视，这时才意识到他一直在盯着她。珍妮特搬到了公墓的一个较旧区域，打算寻找两座特定的坟墓。当她扫描墓碑时，注意力向下，突然她听到左边有什么动静。
It was the man. He was moving quickly and intently towards her, with her looking his eyes Janet described as frightening. He got so close that she instinctively put her hand up at him in a stopping motion, and nervously stepped backwards. She ate the screened or yelled, but couldn't remember in the heat of the moment. Whatever she did, it startled the man and he walked away. But he didn't leave. Janet spotted his feet poking out from behind a cluster of trees close by.
是那个男人。他正快速而专注地向她走来，珍妮特形容他的眼神很吓人。他靠得太近，以至于她本能地举起手做出阻止的动作，并紧张地向后退。她尖叫或大喊，但在那一刻记不清了。无论她做了什么，都吓到了那个男人，他走开了。但他并没有离开。珍妮特发现他的脚从附近的一丛树后露了出来。
Overcome by fear, she turned and ran, leaping over graves until she reached her husband who was waiting in their car. She told him about the encounter and let him to where the man was hiding. He was nowhere to be seen. Janet didn't consider herself to be easily scared, but she was so troubled by the experience
恐惧感袭来，她转身逃跑，跳过坟墓，直到到达在车里等候的丈夫身边。她告诉他这次遭遇，并带他去了那个男人躲藏的地方。他已经不见踪影了。珍妮特并不认为自己是个容易受惊的人，但这次经历让她感到非常不安，
that she gave up on her research and refused to go back to Faulkner's cemetery. Janet was not the only one who encountered this man in October 1997. His behavior revealed a prolonged campaign of harassment during which lone women in fork nacemmetry were watched, stalked, confronted, and chased. Some noted his prescription glasses with thin gold frames. He once donned blue overalls akin to those worn by tradesmen. No one saw him carrying a weapon, though he kept his right hand in his jacket pocket as though hiding something. The women either dismissed the man's actions as misinterpreted and likely harmless,
以至于她放弃了研究，拒绝再回到福克纳公墓。珍妮特并不是1997年10月唯一遇到这个男人的人。他的行为揭示了一场长期的骚扰活动，期间福克纳公墓的独行女性被监视、跟踪、对峙和追赶。一些人注意到他戴着细金框的处方眼镜。他曾穿过类似技工穿的蓝色工作服。没有人看到他携带武器，尽管他把右手放在夹克口袋里，好像在隐藏什么。女性们要么认为这个男人的行为是被误解的，很可能是无害的，
or chose not to report him out of fear that he was indeed dangerous. On the morning of Saturday, November 1, Limaimer Berman was maintaining the Latvian Memorial section of Faulkner's cemetery when the man approached. Reaking of alcohol, he introduced himself as John Roberts. He kept his hands in his jacket pockets as he engaged Limer in conversation. Twice he motioned to a nearby hedge and asked what was behind it. He then pointed out a nearby grave and said it belonged to his adoptive mother. Lama sensed something unusual about the man.
要么因为担心他确实危险而选择不举报他。11月1日星期六早上，利迈默·伯曼正在维护福克纳公墓的拉脱维亚纪念区，这时那个男人走了过来。他浑身酒气，自称是约翰·罗伯茨。他把手放在夹克口袋里，与利迈默交谈。他两次示意附近的一个树篱，问后面是什么。然后他指着附近的一座坟墓，说那是他养母的。利迈默感觉到这个男人有些不寻常。
She felt like he was trying to lead her away. She offered him a rake to tidy the graves side of his adoptive mother and carried on with her work. Later, Lama went by the grave the men had singled out. It remained in an neglected state. Throughout the day, the same men was spotted multiple times. After 3pm, a woman noticed him coming towards her, but he backed off when her boyfriend approached. Shortly before 4pm, the cemetery's mournful silence was shattered
她觉得他想把她引开。她递给他一把耙子，让他清理他养母的墓地，然后继续她的工作。后来，利迈默经过那个男人指出的坟墓。它仍然处于被忽视的状态。整整一天，同一个男人被多次发现。下午3点后，一名女性注意到他向她走来，但当她的男朋友走近时，他退缩了。下午4点前不久，公墓哀伤的寂静被打破了
by a woman's sharp and sudden scream. It was coming from the north, where the Greek Orthodox memorial was located. A second scream rang out barely a minute later. The cries decreased in pitch and volume before gradually turning into subdued moaning. The area soon fell silent again. At 6.45pm, Angelo Gorgavski arrived home from work to find his house unusually quiet and empty. His fiance, 25-year-old Messina Halvagas, should have been there. The couple were planning to have dinner out together and Messina was typically reliable, but hours passed with no sign of her.
一声尖锐而突然的女性尖叫声。声音来自北面，希腊东正教纪念碑所在地。不到一分钟后，第二声尖叫响起。哭喊声的音调和音量逐渐降低，最后变成了压抑的呻吟。该区域很快又陷入了寂静。下午6点45分，安杰洛·戈尔加夫斯基下班回家，发现家里异常安静且空无一人。他的未婚妻，25岁的梅西娜·哈尔瓦加斯本应在那里。这对夫妇计划一起出去吃晚饭，梅西娜通常很可靠，但几个小时过去了，依然没有她的踪影。
Angelo was aware that Messina had planned to visit Fork Messimetry earlier that afternoon. Although she didn't like Semitries, Messina visited her grandmother's grave fortnightly to pray, lay flowers, or light a candle. It was still dark at 4.30am when Angelo arrived at the cemetery to see if Messina was there. The grounds were closed, but Messina's locked car was alone in the parking lot. Angelo called the police and escorted officers to the Greek Orthodox section where Missina's grandmother was buried. They wandered down Rhoam and came across Missina Halvaga's not far from her grandmother's grave, lying between two headstones.
安杰洛知道梅西娜计划那天下午早些时候去福克纳公墓。虽然她不喜欢公墓，但梅西娜每两周会去她祖母的坟墓祈祷、献花或点蜡烛。凌晨4点30分，天还没亮，安杰洛就赶到公墓看梅西娜是否在那里。公墓大门紧闭，但梅西娜锁着的车独自停在停车场。安杰洛报了警，并陪同警察前往梅西娜祖母安葬的希腊东正教区。他们沿着路走，在离她祖母坟墓不远的地方发现了梅西娜·哈尔瓦加斯，她躺在两块墓碑之间。
She had been stabbed to death in a frenzy attack. The ground around her was covered in blood, as were the surrounding headstones. Flowers scattered across the scene indicated that Messina had been set upon unexpectedly while tending to her grandmother's grave. A chaotic altercation ensued, with Messina's glasses and shoes coming off during the fight. Messina's attacker pulled her upper clothing over her head. The garments remained tangled in her arms and bunched up around her chest, partially exposing her bra. Injuries to Messina's hands showed she'd fought desperately for control of the knife. She endured 85 injuries
她在一场疯狂的袭击中被刺死。她周围的地面上满是鲜血，周围的墓碑也是如此。散落在现场的花朵表明，梅西娜在照料她祖母的坟墓时遭到了意外袭击。随后发生了混乱的争斗，梅西娜的眼镜和鞋子在打斗中脱落。梅西娜的袭击者把她的上衣拉过头顶。衣服缠在她的手臂上，堆在她的胸前，部分露出了她的胸罩。梅西娜手上的伤痕显示她曾为夺刀而拼命反抗。她总共遭受了85处伤害，
in total, including stab wounds to her neck, abdomen and limbs. The killer had zeroed in on Messina's chest and breasts, which featured severe wounds. The crime was particularly disconcerting as Messina had been killed just before 4pm in broad daylight in an inhabited public space. The motive also wasn't abundantly clear. Messina Halvagas, who worked for a bank, was described as selfless and caring. Her family was close-knit, she had no known enemies, and she had an expressed concern for her safety prior to her death.
包括颈部、腹部和四肢的刺伤。凶手专门针对梅西娜的胸部和乳房，那里有严重的伤口。这起犯罪特别令人不安，因为梅西娜是在下午4点前不久，在光天化日之下的有人居住的公共场所被杀害的。动机也不十分明确。在银行工作的梅西娜·哈尔瓦加斯被描述为无私和体贴。她的家庭关系紧密，没有已知的敌人，她在去世前曾表达过对自身安全的担忧。
The killer had likely been covered in blood, yet they only had to run 40 meters to reach the carpark to escape without being seen. Every bush and blade of grass around the crime scene was checked, as well as the Craigbed nearby. All potential clues were thoroughly examined, including several cigarette parts found at the crime scene, and unique tyre tracks in the parking lot. But it was soon realized that Miss Sinus killer hadn't left anything behind that could lead to their identification. Her heartbroken family fronted the press
凶手身上很可能沾满了鲜血，但他们只需跑40米就能到达停车场逃离，而没有被任何人看到。犯罪现场周围的每一丛灌木和每一片草叶都经过了检查，附近的克雷吉本也是如此。所有潜在的线索都经过了彻底检查，包括在犯罪现场发现的几根香烟头，以及停车场独特的轮胎痕迹。但很快人们意识到，梅西娜的凶手没有留下任何可以导致他们身份识别的东西。她心碎的家人面对媒体，
requesting the public's help. Her father said, every day is nothing but misery in our house. There has to be someone who knows something or suspects something. It's not going to make me feel better, but at least we would know who did it. Visitors to the cemetery on the day of the killing came forward to report what they now
请求公众的帮助。她的父亲说：“我们家每天都只有痛苦。一定有人知道什么或怀疑什么。这不会让我感觉好受些，但至少我们会知道是谁干的。”在杀戮当天访问公墓的游客站出来报告了他们现在
believed was the sound of Messina screaming mid-attack. As none had reported or investigated the screams, the cemetery gates were closed at 8 p.m., with Messina lying dead within. More reports soon came in of the frightening men who distalked women in the week's leading up to Messina's death. Witnesses placed him in the cemetery on the day Messina was targeted, where he had looted for hours. Police were certain he was Messina's killer, and that every other encounter was a
认为是梅西娜在袭击中尖叫的声音。由于没有人报告或调查这些尖叫声，公墓大门在晚上8点关闭，而梅西娜就躺在里面。不久后，更多关于在梅西娜去世前几周跟踪女性的可怕男人的报告传了进来。证人将他安置在梅西娜遇害当天的公墓，他在那里徘徊了几个小时。警方确信他就是梅西娜的凶手，而其他每一次遭遇都是
fortunate near-miss. This told detectives that they weren't dealing with an irrational person, but a cold and calculated killer with the presence of mind to stalk and hide. A photo fit of the stalker was publicised and a million dollar reward was offered. fit of the stalker was publicized and a million dollar reward was offered. Six large binders were filled with information pertaining to the Havagas case. Detectives worked 18 hours a day pursuing 400 leads and questioning 1500 people. Several suspects were interviewed, but no charges were laid. Macinus' mother rast herself between sobs. Why? Why us?
幸运的死里逃生。这告诉侦探们，他们面对的不是一个非理性的人，而是一个冷静且精于算计的杀手，有跟踪和隐藏的心理准备。跟踪者的模拟画像被公开，并悬赏一百万美元。六个大活页夹里装满了与哈尔瓦加斯案有关的信息。侦探们每天工作18小时，追踪400条线索，询问了1500人。几名嫌疑人接受了讯问，但没有提出指控。梅西娜的母亲在啜泣中问自己：“为什么？为什么是我们？”
What did we ever do to deserve this? Meanwhile, the investigation into the murder of Margaret Ma in Summerton had also gone cold. A year and a half passed with no breakthroughs. Then at 7pm on Monday, April 19, 1999, Rena Hoffman approached the weatherboard cottage rented by her good friend, Nicole Patterson. 28-year-old Nicole worked from home in the suburb of Northcut, a short distance from Melbourne's CBD. The pair had dinner plans that night, but Reena was running late.
“我们到底做了什么才招致这种报应？”与此同时，对萨默顿玛格丽特·马谋杀案的调查也陷入了僵局。一年半过去了，没有任何突破。然后，在1999年4月19日星期一晚上7点，丽娜·霍夫曼走近她好朋友妮可·帕特森租住的木板小屋。28岁的妮可在家工作，位于距离墨尔本中央商务区不远的诺斯科特郊区。两人那天晚上有晚餐计划，但丽娜迟到了。
She had left a message on Nicole's mobile to let her know, but hadn't heard anything back. Reena parked her car outside Nicole's home on Harper Street and made her way up the driveway, where a light illuminated the veranda. Rina rang the doorbell. Nicole's dog Bella started barking from the backyard, but Nicole didn't appear. Rina rang the doorbell several more times and waited. Rina rang the doorbell several more times and waited. Growing concerned, she forced herself in. Nicole's home was lived in, but tidy. Lights were on throughout, and music was playing from a radio in the lounge room.
她在妮可的手机上留了言告知她，但没有收到任何回复。丽娜把车停在哈珀街妮可家外面，沿着车道走上去，那里有一盏灯照亮了门廊。丽娜按了门铃。妮可的狗贝拉在后院叫了起来，但妮可没有出现。丽娜又按了几次门铃，等待着。丽娜又按了几次门铃，等待着。越来越担心的她强行进入了屋内。妮可的家有人居住，但很整洁。灯光亮着，休息室里的收音机播放着音乐。
Rina headed towards a room at the front of the house, used as Nicole's home office. There, she found Nicole lying on the floor face up in the crucifix position. She was naked from the waist to down, with her underwear looped around one ankle. Her cardigan was pushed up, revealing what appeared to be an orange or yellow top underneath. The carpet around Nicole's body was soaked red, and deep gashes were visible along her wrists. Reena rushed to a phone in the lounge room and called emergency services. The operator instructed her to check if Nicole was still breathing.
丽娜走向房子前部的一个房间，那里被用作妮可的家庭办公室。在那里，她发现妮可脸朝上躺在地板上，呈十字架姿势。她腰部以下赤裸，内衣缠绕在一只脚踝上。她的开衫被推上去，露出了下面看起来像是橙色或黄色的上衣。妮可尸体周围的地毯被染成了红色，手腕上有深深的伤口。丽娜冲到休息室的电话旁，拨打了紧急服务电话。接线员指示她检查妮可是否还有呼吸。
Nicole didn't react to Reena's voice or touch. Her skin was cold and her pulse was imperceptible. Reena placed her hand on Nicole's chest to see if she could feel a rising and falling. Nicole's bra was a skew and Reena quickly realized she had been mistaken. Her friend wasn't wearing an orange or yellow top. It was fatty tissue. Nicole's breasts had been removed. The brutal depravity of Nicole Paterson's murder confronted the seasoned homicide detectives
妮可对丽娜的声音或触摸没有反应。她的皮肤冰冷，脉搏无法察觉。丽娜把手放在妮可的胸口，看是否能感觉到起伏。妮可的胸罩歪了，丽娜很快意识到她弄错了。她的朋友穿的不是橙色或黄色的上衣。那是脂肪组织。妮可的乳房被切除了。妮可·帕特森谋杀案的残酷堕落让经验丰富的凶杀案侦探们感到震惊，
tasked with investigating the crime. She had sustained 27 stab wounds to her back, chest, abdomen and limbs. Further incisions in her thigh, wrists and hands were deemed defensive. There were no signs of forced entry into Nicole's home. The rear door was locked as were all the windows. Nicole's large dog was secured in the backyard, meaning the killer had likely entered from the front. The presence of Mug's and a spilled coffee pot in Nicole's office suggested that she'd
他们负责调查这起犯罪。她的背部、胸部、腹部和四肢遭受了27处刺伤。大腿、手腕和手上的进一步切口被认为是防御性的。妮可家没有强行进入的迹象。后门锁着，所有窗户也锁着。妮可的大狗被关在后院，这意味着凶手很可能是从前门进入的。妮可办公室里马克杯和洒出的咖啡壶表明，她
engaged her killer with pleasantries before the attack. She was struck as her back was turned. It couldn't be ascertained with absolute certainty that Nicole had been sexually assaulted. However, what came next was deemed sexually motivated. Once the bulk of the attack was over, Nicole was rolled onto her back. Her top was cut away with scissors and her breasts were removed with a knife in a ragged soaring motion. Nicole's killer then moved throughout her house, leaving blood stains on a hallway wall,
在袭击前曾与凶手进行了愉快的交谈。她在背对凶手时遭到了袭击。无法绝对确定妮可是否受到了性侵犯。然而，接下来的事情被认为是出于性动机。袭击结束后，妮可被翻过身来。她的上衣被剪刀剪开，乳房被一把刀以粗糙的锯割动作切除。妮可的凶手随后在她的房子里走动，在走廊墙壁、
interior door jam, the front door, and inside her bedroom. Nicole's breasts weren't found at the crime scene, indicating the killer might have taken them as a souvenir. Her purse and a driver's license were also missing. Residents along Harper Street were stunned by news of the murder, recalling that Nicole was a lovely and happy young woman. No one had witnessed anyone coming or going from Nicole's home on Monday, April 19, but one neighbor had heard something strange.
室内门框、前门和卧室里留下了血迹。妮可的乳房在犯罪现场没有被发现，这表明凶手可能把它们当作纪念品带走了。她的钱包和驾照也不见了。哈珀街的居民对谋杀案的消息感到震惊，回忆起妮可是一个可爱而快乐的年轻女性。没有人目击到4月19日星期一有人进出妮可的家，但一位邻居听到了一些奇怪的事情。
They were walking past the Nicole's home just after 9am when they heard a woman yell twice. You fucking can't. She didn't sound angry, just upset. The passer-by assumed it was a domestic argument and carried on, unwilling to pry. Another neighbor named Bruce Thompson lived three doors down from Nicole. He was smoking on his veranda just after 9am when he heard what sounded like an injured woman scream from the direction of Nicole's home. Bruce looked up the street but didn't see anything untoward.
他们在上午9点刚过经过妮可家时，听到一名女性大喊两次：“你他妈的不能这样。”她听起来并不生气，只是心烦意乱。路人以为这是一场家庭争吵，便继续前行，不愿打听。另一位名叫布鲁斯·汤普森的邻居住在离妮可家三个门远的地方。上午9点刚过，他正在门廊上抽烟，听到妮可家方向传来类似受伤女性的尖叫声。布鲁斯抬头看了看街道，但没有看到任何异常。
He stayed outside for a little longer just in case. Soon, he spotted a stocky, short-statured man walking intently with his hands in his pockets towards Westgarth Street. They locked eyes and Bruce gave a friendly nod, but the man carried on without responding. Bruce didn't recall seeing any blood on the man which correlated with the crime scene. While Nicole's injuries were extensive, they weren't the type to cause extensive blood splatter. None of her arteries had been nicked and her breasts were removed post-mortem.
他在外面多待了一会儿以防万一。很快，他看到一个身材矮壮的男人把手放在口袋里，专注地向西加斯街走去。他们对视了一眼，布鲁斯友好地点了点头，但那个男人没有回应就继续走了。布鲁斯不记得看到那个男人身上有任何血迹，这与犯罪现场相符。虽然妮可的伤势很严重，但并不是那种会导致大量血迹喷溅的类型。她的动脉没有被割破，乳房是在死后被切除的。
Any mild splatter her killer might have received could have been absorbed by his clothing, leaving little visible. Detectives believed the man Bruce had witnessed was Nicole's killer, whose car was likely parked in West Garth Street. Scraps of note paper found next to Nicole's answering machine provided a clue. Scrauled in her handwriting at the top of one page was the name Malcolm. The word depression was written underneath. Nicole was a certified psychotherapist and a youth worker.
凶手身上可能沾到的任何轻微喷溅都可能被他的衣服吸收，几乎看不见。侦探们认为布鲁斯目击的那个男人就是妮可的凶手，他的车很可能停在西加斯街。在妮可的答录机旁边发现的纸条碎片提供了一条线索。其中一页纸的顶部用她的笔迹潦草地写着“马尔科姆”这个名字。下面写着“抑郁”这个词。妮可是一名认证心理治疗师和青年工作者。
Described as someone always willing to help others, she had established a private practice at her home. In an attempt to grow her client base, Nicole advertised her services in the North-Curt Leader newspaper. The weekend before her death, Nicole spoke to her friends and family about the very first client she'd taken on named Malcolm. He'd seen Nicole's newspaper ad and booked a session at her home for 9am the day she was killed. Nicole didn't elaborate out of respect for confidentiality, but she was looking forward to the meeting.
她被描述为一个总是乐于助人的人，并在家里建立了私人诊所。为了扩大客户群，妮可还在《诺斯科特领袖报》上为她的服务做了广告。在她去世前的那个周末，妮可向她的朋友和家人谈到了她接手的第一个客户，名叫马尔科姆。他看到了妮可的报纸广告，并预约了她遇害当天上午9点的会话。出于对保密的尊重，妮可没有详述，但她很期待这次会面。
There was evidence that the killer had cleaned up after himself by wiping down surfaces and had scoured the home for clues before fleeing. Detectives knew they were dealing with an experienced defender who knew how to beat the system, yet he'd missed something very important. Nicole's appointment book was hidden under clothing and couch cushions in the lounge room. In it, she had noted her meeting with Malcolm and circled it. Most importantly, she had also jotted down a mobile phone number. The number was traced to a 24-year-old international student named Harbourgunn Coley, locally known as Harry. He told police that he had purchased the number as part of a phone plan in mid-March 1999,
有证据表明，凶手在逃离前通过擦拭表面并搜寻线索清理了现场。侦探们知道他们面对的是一个知道如何打败系统的老练罪犯，但他错过了一件非常重要的事情。妮可的预约簿被藏在休息室的衣服和沙发垫下。在里面，她记录了与马尔科姆的会面并圈了出来。最重要的是，她还记下了一个手机号码。该号码被追踪到一名24岁的国际学生，名叫哈尔布贡·科利，当地人称他为哈里。他告诉警方，他在1999年3月中旬购买了这个号码作为电话套餐的一部分，
a little over a month before Nicole was killed. It was just after Harry had arrived in Melbourne from India to study a master's of business administration. Harry assured police that the phone had remained in his possession the entire time, and no one else had used it. Detectives placed Harry under covert surveillance to see if he did anything that would elevate him as a suspect. All they determined was that he was a normal,
在妮可遇害前一个多月。那是哈里从印度来到墨尔本攻读工商管理硕士学位后不久。哈里向警方保证，手机一直由他保管，没有其他人使用过。侦探们对哈里进行了秘密监视，看他是否会做出任何让他成为嫌疑人的举动。他们确定的只是他是一个正常的、
law-abiding young man. Speaking with Harry again, detectives learned that he'd recently applied for general labor, cleaning, and gardening work. He was given a contact to name to Peter, who told him work would commence in mid-May. Harry provided Peter with his mobile number so that he could be contacted closer to the start date.
守法的年轻人。再次与哈里交谈时，侦探们得知他最近申请了普通劳工、清洁和园艺工作。他得到了一个联系人名字叫彼得，彼得告诉他工作将在5月中旬开始。哈里向彼得提供了他的手机号码，以便在接近开始日期时联系他。
Detectives believed Peter had contacted Nicole Patterson under the fake name Malcolm, using Harry's number as his own so that it couldn't be traced back to him. It was a clever and calculated cover-up, but flawed. Phone records from Nicole's landline revealed she had received 15 calls from a number in the lead-up to her fatal meeting. The number was associated with the landline in the suburb of Pasco Vale and registered to a man named Peter Dupasse. us. Case file will be back shortly.
侦探们认为彼得以假名马尔科姆联系了妮可·帕特森，使用哈里的号码作为自己的号码，这样就无法追溯到他。这是一个聪明且经过计算的掩盖，但有缺陷。来自妮可座机的电话记录显示，她在致命会面前夕收到了来自该号码的15个电话。该号码与帕斯科谷郊区的座机有关，并注册在一个名叫彼得·杜帕斯的人名下。案件档案很快就会回来。
Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. This episode of Case file is sponsored by BetterHelp. How much of your time do you devote to looking after others? Friends, coworkers, partners, kids? You spend so much time getting caught up in what everyone around you needs. But what about what you need for yourself? When we spend all our time looking after our loved ones,
感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。本集《案件档案》由BetterHelp赞助。您花多少时间照顾他人？朋友、同事、伴侣、孩子？您花太多时间纠结于周围每个人需要什么。但您自己需要什么呢？当我们花所有时间照顾我们所爱的人时，
it can leave us feeling stretched, thin and burned out. At CaseFile, we know how important it is to look after your mental health. Therapy is more than just talking about your problems, and it's not just for those who've experienced major trauma. Therapy can teach you positive coping skills and show you how to set boundaries. It empowers you to be the best version of yourself while giving you the tools to find more balance in your life, so you can keep supporting others without leaving yourself behind. As the saying goes, you can't pour from an empty cup. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give better help a try. It's entirely online and designed to be convenient,
这会让我们感到精疲力竭和枯竭。在《案件档案》，我们知道照顾您的心理健康有多重要。治疗不仅仅是谈论您的问题，也不仅仅是针对那些经历过重大创伤的人。治疗可以教您积极的应对技巧，并向您展示如何设定界限。它使您能够成为最好的自己，同时为您提供工具来在生活中找到更多平衡，这样您就可以继续支持他人而不至于丢掉自己。俗话说，空杯无法倒水。如果您正在考虑开始治疗，请尝试BetterHelp。它完全在线，旨在方便、
flexible and suited to your schedule. To get started, all you have to do is fill out a brief questionnaire and you'll be matched with a licensed therapist, and you can switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Find more balance with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com-casefile today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com-casefile. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Three decades earlier, on the afternoon of Thursday, October 3, 1968,
灵活并适合您的日程安排。要开始，您只需填写一份简短的问卷，您就会被匹配到一位持证治疗师，并且您可以随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。通过BetterHelp找到更多平衡。立即访问BetterHelp.com-casefile，您的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com-casefile。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持《案件档案》继续提供高质量的内容。三十年前，1968年10月3日星期四下午，
15-year-old Peter Dupasse left his home in the inland suburb of Mount Waverley, Victoria. After a short and purposeful walk, he arrived at his neighbor's house and knocked on their back door. Dupasse was well acquainted with his neighbors and got along well with the man of their house. But he wasn't home that day. Only his wife, 27-year-old Anne accursed was. She was nursing their 5-week-old baby. Anne opened the laundry door to Dupas, who was still wearing his uniform after a day at school. With urgency, Dupas asked to borrow a sharp knife to peel
15岁的彼得·杜帕斯离开了他位于维多利亚州芒特韦弗利内陆郊区的家。经过一段简短而有目的的步行，他到达了邻居的家，敲了他们的后门。杜帕斯很了解他的邻居，和他们家的人相处得很好。但他那天不在家。只有他的妻子，27岁的安妮·阿库尔斯在。她正在照顾他们5周大的婴儿。安妮打开洗衣房的门给杜帕斯，他放学后还穿着校服。杜帕斯急切地要求借一把锋利的刀来削
some potatoes for his mother. After commending him for being a good son, En retrieved a small knife and handed it over. Dupas stood silently with the knife's blade pointed towards En. He then launched himself towards her. Peter, what's wrong, Anne asked frantically, as he forced her to the ground by her hair. The teenager strutled Anne before wordlessly slushing at her hands face and neck, wounded and bloody, Anne desperately tried to grab the knife while begging to be let go. Jupas replied, It's too late in, I can't stop now, they'll lock me up. Losing strength against the determined teen, end screened as loud as she could.
一些土豆给他母亲。在称赞他是个好儿子后，安妮取出一把小刀递给了他。杜帕斯沉默地站着，刀刃指向安妮。然后他向她扑去。“彼得，怎么了？”安妮惊慌地问，他抓住她的头发把她按倒在地。这名少年勒住安妮，随后一言不发地割向她的手、脸和脖子。受伤且血流不止的安妮拼命想抓住刀，同时恳求他放过她。杜帕斯回答：“太晚了，安妮，我不能停下来，他们会把我关起来的。”在坚定的少年面前失去力量，安妮尽可能大声地尖叫。
Peter Jupas covered Anne's mouth and knows with the palm of his free hand, then pushed his fingers down her throat to silence her. Just as he began to bash Anne's head against the floor, Dupas went still. As if moving in slow motion, he looked at the knife and turned it towards himself. Anne wriggled away. She had sustained mostly cuts and bruises across her head and knack. There were several deeper wounds to her fingers and face, which would require a couple of stitches at most.
彼得·杜帕斯用空着的那只手的手掌捂住安妮的嘴和鼻子，然后把手指伸进她的喉咙让她闭嘴。就在他开始把安妮的头撞向地板时，杜帕斯静止了。仿佛在慢动作中移动，他看着刀，把它转向了自己。安妮挣脱了。她的头部和颈部大多是割伤和淤青。她的手指和脸上有几处较深的伤口，最多需要缝几针。
Anne coaxed to Dupasse to hand over the knife. She hid the weapon before returning to Dupasse who broke down in tears and begged her to call the police. In a subsequent police interview, Dupasse offered a no explanation for the attack. He had no criminal history and was described by those who knew him as ordinary. At home, Peter Dupasse's upbringing was reportedly normal. He was treated warmly and lovingly by his taxi driver father and a Tupperware selling mother. They raised Dupasse as an only child, as his two siblings were many years older.
安妮劝说杜帕斯交出刀。她藏起了武器，然后回到杜帕斯身边，他泪流满面，恳求她报警。在随后的警方讯问中，杜帕斯对袭击没有做出任何解释。他没有犯罪记录，被认识他的人描述为普通人。在家里，彼得·杜帕斯的成长环境据说是正常的。他受到出租车司机父亲和卖特百惠的母亲的温暖和爱护。他们把杜帕斯当作独生子抚养，因为他的两个兄弟姐妹大他很多岁。
He was spoiled and never beaten. School was a far more hostile and isolating environment. While Peter Dupasse was well regarded by educators for being polite and quiet, his peers found him strange and unfriendly. View took any notice of him and those that did bullied him for being short and overweight. Prominent deposits of fat formed over his pectoral muscles, which, quote, had the appearance of female breasts and led to further insecurities. Dupasse was physically weak and only got into typical school yard scraps, never showing signs of extreme violence.
他被宠坏了，从未被打过。学校是一个更加敌对和孤立的环境。虽然彼得·杜帕斯因礼貌和安静而受到教育工作者的好评，但他的同龄人觉得他很奇怪且不友好。很少有人注意到他，而那些注意到他的人则因为他个子矮小和超重而欺负他。他的胸肌上形成了明显的脂肪堆积，这“看起来像女性乳房”，并导致了进一步的不安全感。杜帕斯身体虚弱，只卷入过典型的校园打架，从未表现出极端暴力的迹象。
With few friends and limited social skills, Dupasse's life was dominated by his parents. He felt his mother was overprotective and smothering, as he grappled with feelings of inadequacy brought about by his perfectionist father. Following the teen seemingly out of character attack on Ian Akkursd, the courts concluded that he was, quote, Court in an emotional conflict between the need to conform to the expectations of his parents and the unconscious urges to express his aggression and his developing masculinity. Jupas avoided serious punishment and was instead placed on probation for 18 months and ordered
由于朋友很少，社交技能有限，杜帕斯的生活被他的父母所主导。他觉得母亲过度保护和令人窒息，同时他还要应对完美主义父亲带来的无能感。在少年看似反常地袭击安妮·阿库尔斯之后，法院得出结论，他处于“在顺从父母期望的需要与表达攻击性和发展男性气质的潜意识冲动之间的情感冲突中”。杜帕斯避免了严厉的惩罚，而是被判处18个月的缓刑，并被命令
to undergo psychiatric treatment. When speaking in the immediate aftermath of the attack, he explained, I must have been trying to kill Anne or something. I don't know why I was trying to do this. As far as I'm concerned, there is no reason for me to do anything to her. But, I couldn't help myself. During psychiatric observation, Peter Dupasse was considered a model young man. He seemed caring and helpful and was released from hospital within two weeks. By March 1972, 18-year-old D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D.
接受精神病治疗。在袭击发生后的第一时间谈话时，他解释说：“我一定是想杀了安妮什么的。我不知道我为什么要这样做。就我而言，我没有任何理由对她做任何事。但是，我无法控制自己。”在精神病观察期间，彼得·杜帕斯被认为是一个模范年轻人。他看起来很关心人且乐于助人，并在两周内出院。到1972年3月，18岁的杜帕斯
By March 1972, 18-year-old D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. By March 1972, 18-year-old D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. By March 1972, 18-year-old D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. By March 1972, 18 approached a residence and appeared through a bathroom window. There was a woman shiring inside. Her husband spotted Jupas peeping and a chase in chute. When apprehended, Jupas asserted that he had only been taking a shortcut through the couple's yard to get to his car. He was given a $50 fine. Almost two years later in November 1973, police arrived at the Dupasse home and requested
到1972年3月，18岁的杜帕斯接近了一处住宅，并透过浴室窗户窥视。里面有一名女性在洗澡。她的丈夫发现了杜帕斯在窥视，随后展开了追逐。被捕时，杜帕斯声称他只是抄近路穿过这对夫妇的院子去取车。他被罚款50美元。近两年后的1973年11月，警察来到杜帕斯家，要求
Peter Dupasse accompany them back to the station. When he asked if the matter would take long, the officers informed him that they were inquiring about a rape. Jupas became flustered. The officers told him, if you are not involved, you have nothing to worry about. Jupas started to cry and told his father, I don't want to go with them. His father asked how his son came to be a suspect in the rape.
彼得·杜帕斯陪他们回警局。当他问这件事是否需要很长时间时，警官告诉他，他们正在调查一起强奸案。杜帕斯变得慌乱起来。警官告诉他：“如果你没有参与，你就没什么可担心的。”杜帕斯开始哭泣，并告诉他的父亲：“我不想和他们一起去。”他的父亲问他的儿子是怎么成为强奸案嫌疑人的。
Two weeks earlier in the nearby suburb of Mitchum, 23-year-old Caroline Bottom was at home with her 18-month-old son when there was a knock at the front door. It was a man Caroline didn't know. He gestured towards a red car parked on the street with its bonnet up, saying that it had broken down. He asked if he could use Caroline's phone, then remarked that he might be able to fix it himself if she had a screwdriver. As Caroline went to retrieve one, the man entered her home. He pulled out a knife and grabbed Caroline's baby to force her to comply before binding the frightened mother with a cord and violently raping her. In the next fortnight two other women reported incidents
两周前，在附近的米彻姆郊区，23岁的卡罗琳·博顿正带着她18个月大的儿子在家，这时前门响起了敲门声。来的是一个卡罗琳不认识的男人。他指着街上停着的一辆引擎盖掀开的红色汽车，说车坏了。他问能不能借用卡罗琳的电话，随后又说如果她有螺丝刀，他或许能自己修好。当卡罗琳去取螺丝刀时，那个男人闯进了她的家。他掏出一把刀，抓住卡罗琳的孩子强迫她就范，随后用绳子捆住惊恐的母亲，并对她进行了残暴的强奸。在接下来的两周里，又有两名女性报告了类似事件。
involving a man entering their home after requesting a screwdriver for his broken down car. In the first case, he only stole money and fled. He left the second woman's house abruptly when she said that her husband would be back shortly. Peter Dupasse and his car were positively identified by all three women. The now 21-year-old faced charges for house breaking, house breaking with intent to commit a felony and rape.
涉及一名男子在借用螺丝刀修理故障车辆后闯入她们家中。在第一起案件中，他只偷了钱就逃跑了。在第二起案件中，当那名女子说她丈夫很快就会回来时，他匆忙离开了。彼得·杜帕斯及其车辆被这三名女性明确指认。现年21岁的他面临入室盗窃、意图实施重罪的入室盗窃以及强奸罪的指控。
The trial judge stated, This was one of the worst rapes that could be imagined. You invaded the sanctity of her home by a false story, relying upon her willingness to help in order to gain admission. You threatened her with a knife, you tied her up with a cord, you struck her, and worst of all, you threatened to harm her baby when she tried to resist. The judge reflected on Jupas' 1968 attack the neighbour Ian Atkhurst, a psychiatric report at the time asserted that Dupasse had lost normal control when becoming overwhelmed by pent-up feelings of sexual needs and aggression.
主审法官表示：“这是可以想象到的最恶劣的强奸案之一。你编造谎言侵犯了她神圣的家园，利用她的善意骗取了进入的机会。你用刀威胁她，用绳子捆绑她，殴打她，最糟糕的是，当她试图反抗时，你还威胁要伤害她的孩子。”法官回顾了杜帕斯1968年袭击邻居伊恩·阿克赫斯特的案件，当时的一份精神病学报告断言，杜帕斯在被压抑的性需求和攻击性冲动淹没时，失去了正常的控制力。
The judge overseeing Peter Dupasse's rape trial rejected this explanation for his most recent offending, saying, This was no sudden impulse because you must have left home that morning armed with a knife and provided with the cord to bind your victim. Given that Joupas had entered two other women's homes under similar pre-tances, further indicated that he was driven by pre-meditation and not impulse. further indicated that he was driven by premeditation and not impulse. Little could be ascertained from psychiatric examination of Jupas as he wouldn't admit any guilt. It was believed he used denial as a coping mechanism and he was diagnosed with an undefined psychosexual problem.
负责彼得·杜帕斯强奸案审判的法官驳回了对他最近犯罪行为的这种解释，称：“这绝非突发冲动，因为你那天早上离开家时一定随身携带了刀具，并准备了捆绑受害者的绳子。”鉴于杜帕斯曾以类似借口进入另外两名女性家中，这进一步表明他是蓄谋已久，而非一时冲动。对杜帕斯的精神病学检查几乎无法得出结论，因为他不承认任何罪行。人们认为他将否认作为一种应对机制，他被诊断出患有一种未定义的性心理问题。
In a letter to the prosecution, a detective wrote, Peter Dupasse is a very dangerous young person who will continue to offend where females are concerned, and will possibly cause the death of one of his victims if he is not straightened out. Peter Dupasse was found guilty and sentenced to accumulative six-month incarceration for each of the breaking counts, with a further nine years for Caroline's rape. Dupasse remained a placid and compliant prisoner in preparation for his first parole bid. He said he felt certain he wouldn't reaffant, and his supportive parents saw his release as early as possible.
在一封给检方的信中，一名侦探写道：“彼得·杜帕斯是一个非常危险的年轻人，只要有女性在场，他就会继续犯罪，如果不加以矫正，他很可能会导致其中一名受害者死亡。”彼得·杜帕斯被判有罪，每项入室盗窃罪被判处六个月监禁，累计执行，外加卡罗琳强奸案的九年刑期。杜帕斯在准备首次假释申请期间，一直是一名温顺且配合的囚犯。他说他确信自己不会再犯，他那支持他的父母也希望他能尽早获释。
A report by a parole officer revealed that psychiatric treatment for Dupasse's type of personality disorder had been ineffective. Although marking Peta Dupasse as an ongoing threat to the community, the officer recommended he be paroled on the condition that he have a great deal of supervision. Dupasse was released in September 1979, after serving just half of his decade-long sentence. He moved back in with these parents who were now living in the beach side city of Frankston.
一份假释官的报告显示，针对杜帕斯这类人格障碍的精神治疗无效。尽管将彼得·杜帕斯标记为对社区的持续威胁，但假释官仍建议在严密监管的条件下对他进行假释。杜帕斯于1979年9月获释，此时他仅服完了十年刑期的一半。他搬回了父母身边，他们当时住在海滨城市弗兰克斯顿。
Joupas was required to receive outpatient treatment at a psychiatric hospital. He was permitted to come and go as he pleased and to know arrival or departure records were kept. Shortly after Joupas' release at a campsite in the seaside town of McCray, some young girls were bathing in a women's shower block when they spotted a man at the open doorway watching them. One of the girls screamed, causing him to flee. When two more incidents were reported, police conducted a stakeout of the amenities and
杜帕斯被要求在一家精神病院接受门诊治疗。他被允许自由出入，且没有保留任何到达或离开的记录。在杜帕斯获释后不久，在海滨小镇麦克雷的一个露营地，一些年轻女孩在女淋浴间洗澡时，发现门口站着一个男人在偷看她们。其中一个女孩尖叫起来，导致他逃跑了。当又有两起类似事件被报告后，警方对该设施进行了蹲守，并
caught Peter Dupasse in the act. Although he denied peeping on anyone, he was charged with loitering with intent and offensive behaviour and fined $140. On the night of Friday, November 9, Nina Caden entered a women's toilet block in Frankston. As she went to leave the cubicle, Nina was confronted at knife point by a man wearing a balaclava. He ordered her to do as he said or she'd be killed. The man pushed Nina back into the cubicle and proceeded to rape her. When other people entered the toilet block, the assailant pressed his knife to Nina's
当场抓获了彼得·杜帕斯。尽管他否认偷窥任何人，但他仍被控意图徘徊和行为不检，并被罚款140美元。11月9日星期五晚上，妮娜·卡登进入了弗兰克斯顿的一个女厕所。当她准备离开隔间时，一名戴着巴拉克拉法帽的男子持刀拦住了她。他命令她听从他的指示，否则就会杀了她。该男子将妮娜推回隔间并强奸了她。当其他人进入厕所时，袭击者将刀抵在妮娜的
throat to keep her quiet. Two nights later, Erika Daines was walking alone down Car Street, a residential road on the Casp of Frankston CBD. She soon realized a man was following her. Unnerved, E Erica quickened her pace. The man matched her speed. When Erica turned to confront him, he rushed in. That's when she noticed the blue balaclava over his face and the knife in his hand.
喉咙上以让她保持安静。两天后，埃里卡·戴恩斯独自走在卡尔街上，这是一条位于弗兰克斯顿市中心边缘的住宅路。她很快意识到有一个男人在跟着她。埃里卡感到不安，加快了脚步。那个男人也加快了速度。当埃里卡转身面对他时，他冲了过来。就在那时，她注意到了他脸上戴着的蓝色巴拉克拉法帽和他手中的刀。
Erica ran into the middle of the road and screamed. Her pursuer gestured to her to quieten down, but when Erica continued to yell, he fled. A week later, just after 9pm on November 18, Dorothy Elmore was walking along the Nipian highway in Frankston when she was grabbed from behind. The elderly woman was dragged to a vacant block of land and forced to the ground by a masked man. Don't scream or I'll kill you, he warned as he struttled Dorothy with a knife in hand. He attempted to remove her cardigan, but Dorothy resisted and screamed, prompting her
埃里卡跑到马路中间尖叫起来。追赶她的人示意她安静，但当埃里卡继续大喊时，他逃跑了。一周后，即11月18日晚上9点刚过，多萝西·埃尔莫尔走在弗兰克斯顿的尼皮恩公路上时，从背后被人抓住。这位老妇人被拖到一块空地上，被一名蒙面男子强行按倒在地。他一边用刀抵住多萝西，一边警告说：“别尖叫，否则我杀了你。”他试图脱掉她的开衫，但多萝西反抗并尖叫起来，促使她的
attacker to run away. Dorothy sustained a knife wound to the left side of her chest that required 14 stitches. The following night, Amanda Foltz was walking along Dandenong Road East, a stretch that ran beside the Frankston railway line when she too was grabbed and dragged to a vacant block of land. Her mask wearing a silent groud as he tried to overpower Amanda, who screamed for attention. The men gave up and fled. Investigations quickly led police to Peter Dupasse, who admitted to carrying out the 10-day spree
袭击者逃跑了。多萝西左胸被刀刺伤，缝了14针。第二天晚上，阿曼达·福尔茨走在丹德农路东侧，这是一条沿着弗兰克斯顿铁路线延伸的路段，她也被人抓住并拖到了一块空地上。戴着面具的袭击者在试图制服阿曼达时发出了沉闷的咕哝声，阿曼达尖叫着求救。那人放弃并逃跑了。调查很快将警方引向了彼得·杜帕斯，他承认实施了为期10天的
of Frankston-based attacks. He said, It's all true, I was going to find a woman to rape. In addition to the knife, Dupasse revealed that he'd also been carrying rope to bind his victims with. He told police. It just comes over me. I can't help myself.
弗兰克斯顿系列袭击案。他说：“这一切都是真的，我当时打算找个女人强奸。”除了刀，杜帕斯还透露他随身携带了绳子来捆绑受害者。他告诉警察：“这种感觉突然就涌上来了。我无法控制自己。”
I have had a problem for about six years. I'm glad I got caught. It all started again about two weeks ago. I just find it hard to mix with people and I haven't many friends. I just don't know what to say." Detectives noted that whenever Dupasse spoke with men, he appeared timid and nervous. He avoided eye contact, speaking quietly with his shoulders hunched forward. Doctors believed that the introverted, cowering loner sought power by scaring women.
“我有这个问题大约六年了。我很高兴我被抓住了。这一切大约两周前又开始了。我只是觉得很难与人相处，也没什么朋友。我不知道该说什么。”侦探们注意到，每当杜帕斯与男性交谈时，他看起来都很胆怯和紧张。他避免眼神接触，说话声音很小，肩膀向前耸着。医生们认为，这个内向、畏缩的独行者通过恐吓女性来寻求权力。
Dupasse was convicted of assault with intent to rob malicious wounding in decent assault and rape. On the surface, the Pudgey baby faced a non-descript man appeared harmless. But when it came to Peter Dupasse, police quickly learned that looks can be deceiving. They found him deceptive, manipulative and intelligent. He knew when to talk, or when to clam up and deny everything to better his outcome. His offending was growing in number and severity. A report stated, number and severity. A report stated, There is little that can be said in Dupasse's favor. He remains an extremely disturbed immature and dangerous man. His release on parole was a mistake. Yet, the police and prosecution were flawed when Peter Dupasse was sentenced to just six
杜帕斯被判犯有蓄意抢劫伤害罪、猥亵罪和强奸罪。表面上，这个长着一张娃娃脸、相貌平平的男人看起来人畜无害。但当涉及到彼得·杜帕斯时，警方很快了解到人不可貌相。他们发现他虚伪、善于操纵且聪明。他知道什么时候该说话，什么时候该闭嘴并否认一切以改善自己的处境。他的犯罪数量和严重程度都在增加。一份报告指出：“杜帕斯几乎没有什么值得称道的地方。他仍然是一个极其不安、不成熟且危险的男人。他获准假释是一个错误。”然而，当彼得·杜帕斯仅被判处六年
and a half years jail. They had formed the when Peter Dupasse was sentenced to just six and a half years jail. They had formed the belief that Dupasse could not be rehabilitated and should be kept away from society. Yet, he was released in February 1985 at age 31, after serving his minimum term of five years. Like McCray and Frankston, the town of Blair Gowry is located within an area along Victoria's south-east coast called the Mornington Peninsula. The Peninsula is a popular destination in the warmer months, but it was quiet on Black Ari Beach when 21-year-old Hannah Gadsden arrived on March 3, 1985. Only a few figures were visible in the distance. She reached the water, stripped down to her bathing suit, then went for a short walk. Upon reaching an area of jagged rocks, Hannah passed a shirtless man who was wearing jeans.
半监禁时，警方和检方的判断出现了失误。他们曾形成一种信念，认为杜帕斯无法被改造，应该与社会隔绝。然而，他在1985年2月年满31岁时获释，此前他服完了五年的最低刑期。像麦克雷和弗兰克斯顿一样，布莱尔高里镇位于维多利亚州东南海岸一个叫莫宁顿半岛的地区。半岛在温暖的月份是一个受欢迎的目的地，但当21岁的汉娜·加兹登于1985年3月3日到达时，布莱尔高里海滩很安静。远处只能看到几个人影。她走到水边，脱掉外衣换上泳装，然后去散了一会儿步。当走到一片锯齿状岩石区时，汉娜经过了一个赤裸上身、穿着牛仔裤的男人。
It was Peter Dupasse. The rocks are sharp Hannah remarked off handedly as they crossed paths. Dupasse smiled and watched as Hannah returned to her things nearby. He then approached her while saying something about a purple-colored starfish and the poor condition of the surf. As Dupas closed in, he swiftly called his arm around Hannah's throat and pressed a knife against her neck. He warned her not to struggle or he'd heard her.
那是彼得·杜帕斯。“岩石很锋利，”汉娜在两人擦肩而过时随口说道。杜帕斯笑了笑，看着汉娜回到附近放东西的地方。然后他走近她，说了一些关于紫色海星和海浪状况不佳的话。当杜帕斯靠近时，他迅速用手臂勒住汉娜的喉咙，并将一把刀抵在她的脖子上。他警告她不要挣扎，否则会伤害她。
Dupas ordered Hannah to get down on the sand. She screamed out, but Dupas clasped his hand over her mouth. Hannah saw the knife on the sand beside her and raged out for it. Dupas noticed and told her not to be foolish. He then raped Hannah. When she asked why he was hurting her, Dupasse didn't respond. Afterwards he asked the petrified young woman if she wanted a lift. When she refused, he left.
杜帕斯命令汉娜趴在沙滩上。她尖叫起来，但杜帕斯用手捂住了她的嘴。汉娜看到身边的沙滩上有一把刀，便伸手去抓。杜帕斯注意到了，告诉她不要做傻事。随后他强奸了汉娜。当她问他为什么要伤害她时，杜帕斯没有回答。事后，他问这个惊恐的年轻女子是否需要搭便车。当她拒绝后，他离开了。
Two men walking along a beach track soon came across crosshanner, who revealed what had happened. One rushed off in search of the assailant while the other helped Hannah to her car to get help. They soon spotted Peter Dupasse, who was walking along a road, unable to find where he parked his car. He was swiftly apprehended. Dupasse initially claimed the encounter was consensual, but eventually confessed otherwise. He'd only been out of prison for four days.
两名走在海滩小路上的男子很快遇到了汉娜，她透露了发生的事情。其中一人冲去寻找袭击者，另一人帮助汉娜回到车里寻求帮助。他们很快发现了彼得·杜帕斯，他正走在路上，找不到自己停车的地方。他很快被捕。杜帕斯最初声称这次相遇是双方自愿的，但最终承认并非如此。他出狱才仅仅四天。
Dupas offered no explanation for his behavior. He claimed he was enjoying laying back on the beach when he saw Hannah Gadsden and couldn't help himself. He said he knew what he did was wrong, adding, I'm sorry for what happened. Everyone was telling me I'm okay now. I never thought it was going to happen again. I only wanted to live a normal life.
杜帕斯对自己的行为没有做出任何解释。他声称自己当时正躺在海滩上休息，看到汉娜·加兹登后就无法控制自己。他说他知道自己做错了，并补充道：“我对发生的事情感到抱歉。每个人都告诉我我现在没问题了。我从没想过这种事会再次发生。我只想过正常人的生活。”
Dupasse was relocated to Frankston Police Station for further processing, where he attempted to take his own life, though police doubted his sincerity. At a trial in June 1985, Jupas pleaded guilty to indecent assault with aggravating circumstances and rape. The judge explained that recidivism rates in cases like his were between 80-90% and that Dupasse was walking around with a loaded time bomb in his pocket. Quote There seems to be a very good chance if you were at large again that some other girl might
杜帕斯被转移到弗兰克斯顿警察局进行进一步处理，在那里他试图自杀，尽管警方怀疑他的诚意。在1985年6月的审判中，杜帕斯承认了加重情节的猥亵罪和强奸罪。法官解释说，像他这类案件的累犯率在80-90%之间，杜帕斯口袋里揣着一颗随时会爆炸的定时炸弹。引用：“如果让你再次逍遥法外，很有可能其他女孩也会……”
suffer in the same way. The judge accepted Peter Dupasse's assertions of remorse, adding, One must have sympathy for you, but the community must also be protected. He slammed the lenient sentence handed to Dupasse previously, saying it was inadequate, and acknowledged that the community would be outraged and apprehensive if Dupas previously, saying it was inadequate, and acknowledged that the community would be outraged and apprehensive if Dupas was a free man. He was sentenced to 12 years imprisonment. He was to serve a minimum that reduces offensive sexual behavior.
遭受同样的痛苦。法官接受了彼得·杜帕斯表示的悔意，并补充说：“人们必须对你表示同情，但社区也必须得到保护。”他抨击了之前给予杜帕斯的宽大判决，称其不充分，并承认如果杜帕斯是一个自由人，社区会感到愤怒和忧虑。他被判处12年监禁。他必须服满最低刑期，以减少攻击性性行为。
Shortly after arriving in prison, Dupasse pantaletta to his parents apologizing for his actions. He blamed his deviancy on vague, extraneous circumstances, saying, the way I feel at the moment and have for ages is that I'm far better off out of it all. I tried, I really tried to work on myself and my problems, but I never felt I was getting anywhere. We'll meet again someday. After writing the letter, Dup passe attempted to take his own life. A psychiatrist described his personality as brittle and concluded that it had taken some considerable time to resolve his issues.
刚进监狱不久，杜帕斯就给父母写信道歉。他将自己的堕落归咎于模糊的外部环境，写道：“我现在的感觉，以及很长一段时间以来的感觉，就是我最好彻底解脱。我尝试过，我真的努力去改善自己和解决我的问题，但我从未觉得有任何进展。我们总有一天会再见面的。”写完这封信后，杜帕斯试图自杀。一位精神科医生形容他的人格脆弱，并得出结论称，解决他的问题需要相当长的时间。
Jou passe's unwillingness to admit the full truth about his offending, hampered rehabilitation efforts. Prescribed to drugs that restricted sexual urges were administered with little success. It was found that he lacked motivation for prolonged treatment, and instead wanted a non-existent quick fix. 52-year-old Grace McConnell was a mental health nurse who came to meet Peter Dupas during his time in the prison psychiatric division. Dupas initially viewed Grace as a motherly figure, given their 16-year age gap. But in time, he became infatuated with her, and eventually admitted to have fallen in love.
杜帕斯不愿承认犯罪的全部真相，阻碍了改造工作。医生给他开了限制性冲动的药物，但收效甚微。人们发现他缺乏长期治疗的动力，反而想要一种不存在的速效疗法。52岁的格蕾丝·麦康奈尔是一名心理健康护士，她在杜帕斯在监狱精神科服刑期间认识了他。考虑到16岁的年龄差距，杜帕斯最初将格蕾丝视为母亲般的形象。但随着时间的推移，他迷恋上了她，并最终承认自己爱上了她。
He told Grace that she could help him come out of himself, and be a normal person. Up until this point, Grace had only fostered a professional relationship with Dupas. Driven by pity, she became closer to him. When he successfully applied to transfer to another prison in rural Victoria, Grace moved to continue their regular visits, even though she suspected he was isolating her. Jupas made Grace write to him every day and displayed jealousy when she didn't give him her full attention. She came to learn that Dupas had a superiority complex and was a possessive, domineering man.
他告诉格蕾丝，她可以帮助他走出自我，成为一个正常人。在此之前，格蕾丝与杜帕斯一直保持着纯粹的职业关系。出于同情，她与他走得更近了。当他成功申请转到维多利亚州农村的另一所监狱时，格蕾丝为了继续他们的定期探视也搬了过去，尽管她怀疑他在孤立她。杜帕斯让格蕾丝每天给他写信，当她没有全神贯注于他时，他会表现出嫉妒。她逐渐了解到杜帕斯有优越感，是一个占有欲强、专横的男人。
Grace was surprised when Dupas asked her to marry him. Despite feeling their relationship was more mother and son than husband and wife, Grace agreed to the union. She felt a moral expectation to quote, help Peter become a useful member of the community. They tied the knot in a prison ceremony. Grace never felt any real love towards Peter Dupasse, nor did she believe he felt any for her. She doubted he had
当杜帕斯向她求婚时，格蕾丝感到很惊讶。尽管觉得他们的关系更像是母子而非夫妻，但格蕾丝还是同意了。她感到一种道德上的期望，即“帮助彼得成为社区中有用的一员”。他们在监狱举行了婚礼。格蕾丝从未对彼得·杜帕斯产生过真正的爱，也不相信他对自己有爱。她怀疑他是否有
the capability. Instead, she believed he viewed her as a possession, like a piece of furniture. Dupas cited his marriage to Grace when he began plotting his parole bid. He referred to her as a beautiful person who would stop him from sexually offending. He attended programs aimed at preparing inmates to return to society and was even approved for temporary release to work for a library, cemetery, and recycling depot. He also took a vocational training course at a local TAFE institution to retrain himself in fitting and machining work. In reference to Dupasse's sex attacks, a psychiatrist reported,
这种能力。相反，她认为他把她视为一种财产，就像一件家具。杜帕斯在开始策划假释申请时提到了他与格蕾丝的婚姻。他称她为一个会阻止他进行性犯罪的美丽的人。他参加了旨在帮助囚犯回归社会的项目，甚至获准临时出狱，在图书馆、墓地和回收站工作。他还参加了当地TAFE机构的职业培训课程，重新学习钳工和机械加工工作。在提到杜帕斯的性侵犯时，一位精神科医生报告说：
he believes all of that is behind him since he understands himself better and has become more assertive. By 1992, Peter Dupasse had served 7 out of his twelve-year prison sentence and was granted release. He settled with Grace in the country town of Woodend. The community were unaware of his violent history. Peter gained work as a maintenance manager while Grace became a cleaner. There's was a humble, uneventful life as Dupas spent most of his spare time in front of the television. He had few interests or hobbies and didn't care for anything in particular.
“他认为这一切都已经过去了，因为他更了解自己，也变得更加自信了。”到1992年，彼得·杜帕斯已经服完了十二年刑期中的7年，并获准释放。他与格蕾丝在伍德恩德小镇定居。社区对他的暴力历史一无所知。彼得找到了一份维修经理的工作，而格蕾丝成为了一名清洁工。他们的生活卑微而平淡，杜帕斯大部分空闲时间都花在电视机前。他几乎没有什么兴趣或爱好，对任何事情都不特别关心。
He confided in Grace about his unhappy childhood and how he was teased by his peers for being overweight. His parents kept their home uncomfortably sterile and argued often. Dupas stopped assured of describing his teen years, though mentioned with a hint of bitterness at having once been engaged to a woman who gave the ring back. Grace and Dupas didn't consummate their marriage until he was out of prison, where he felt it was more appropriate. Grace described to their sex life as basic and said she went along with it, out of a sense of responsibility. While Dupas didn't reveal
他向格蕾丝倾诉了自己不幸的童年，以及他如何因为超重而被同龄人嘲笑。他的父母让家里保持着令人不适的无菌状态，而且经常争吵。杜帕斯对描述自己的青少年时期避重就轻，尽管提到曾与一名退还戒指的女性订婚时，语气中带着一丝苦涩。格蕾丝和杜帕斯直到他出狱后才圆房，因为他觉得那样更合适。格蕾丝形容他们的性生活很基本，并说她出于一种责任感才配合他。虽然杜帕斯没有向格蕾丝透露
any deviant sexual proclivities with Grace, had reached the point where she couldn't bear him touching her. She otherwise appreciated that he was an overall well-mannered, even-tempered man, and believed she had successfully reformed him. He didn't lash out when upset, instead he just sit and stare. He got lost in thought often. Then there were the random moments he'd break out in sweats and begin shaking without ever explaining why. Peter Dupasse stayed out of trouble for the 12 months he was no longer under any supervision. On Monday, January 3, 1994, Lucy Ionz was water skiing with a group of friends at Lake
任何变态的性倾向，但格蕾丝已经到了无法忍受他触碰她的地步。除此之外，她认为他总体上是一个举止得体、脾气温和的人，并相信自己已经成功改造了他。他心烦时不会发火，只是坐着发呆。他经常陷入沉思。还有一些时候，他会莫名其妙地出汗并开始颤抖，却从不解释原因。彼得·杜帕斯在不再受任何监管的12个月里没有惹麻烦。1994年1月3日星期一，露西·伊恩兹和一群朋友在湖边滑水。
Apalok, an hours drive north of Woodland. Lucy went by herself to a women's toilet block, and while inside, her cubicle door pushed inwards. Lucy pressed her hand against the door, and firmly said no to indicate the cubicle was occupied. A long black handled knife suddenly appeared from around the door. A man wearing a cream-colored balaclava tried to squeeze in. Lucy fought to hold the door shut, but the man managed to slash her left hand. Just turn around, he ordered, while trying to force Lucy to face the wall. Her palm and
阿帕洛克，距离伍德恩德一小时车程。露西独自去了女厕所，在里面时，她的隔间门被向内推。露西用手抵住门，坚定地说“不”，表示隔间有人。一把长长的黑色手柄刀突然从门边伸了进来。一名戴着奶油色巴拉克拉法帽的男子试图挤进来。露西拼命抵住门，但那人还是划伤了她的左手。他一边试图强迫露西面对墙壁，一边命令道：“转过去。”她的手掌和
two of her fingers were dripping blood. Lucy knew she was about to be raped, but she tried to remain calm as to not aggravate her assailant. I'm very frightened, she said repeatedly. Just tell me what's going on. The man kept the knife close to her face and neck. When Lucy refused to let him push her against the wall, the man grabbed her right arm and dragged her out of the toilet block. His demeanor then abruptly shifted. He let go of Lucy, put both his hands in the air and told her to go before he left. Lucy glimpsed her attacker heading towards a blue Ford station wagon. She alerted her friends and they rushed at the car just as its driver reversed and spat
两根手指都在滴血。露西知道自己即将被强奸，但她试图保持冷静，以免激怒袭击者。“我非常害怕，”她反复说道，“告诉我到底发生了什么。”那人把刀紧贴着她的脸和脖子。当露西拒绝让他把自己推向墙壁时，那人抓住她的右臂，把她拖出了厕所。他的举止突然发生了转变。他放开了露西，双手举过头顶，告诉她快走，然后离开了。露西瞥见袭击者正朝一辆蓝色福特旅行车走去。她提醒了朋友们，他们冲向那辆车，正好司机倒车并
off. Lucy's friends and fiance gave chase in their own car, eventually meeting up with the blue Ford at around about. It drove on at high speeds before making a sharp left turn onto a dirt road and spinning out of control. When the vehicle came to a stop, the pursuers pulled in front to block it and carefully approached on foot. Upon realizing the driver was unarmed, they grabbed him and forced him out. The police were contacted and the offender taken into custody.
疾驰而去。露西的朋友和未婚夫开着自己的车追了上去，最终在一个环岛处追上了那辆蓝色福特。它高速行驶，随后左转进入一条土路，失控打转。当车辆停下时，追赶者开车挡在前面，小心翼翼地步行靠近。意识到司机没有武器后，他们抓住他并强行将他拖了出来。警方接到通知，罪犯被拘留。
He was identified as Peter Dupasse. A search of his car revealed two makeshift balaclavis, duct tape, condoms, handcuffs, a plastic sheet, and a shovel. There were also three knives, one of which was stained with Lucy Ion's blood. There were traces of her blood on his clothing as well. Dupasse was reluctant to speak to police before contacting a solicitor first. After doing so, he said little else to investigators other than, no comment. Prosecutors were in a difficult position.
他被确认为彼得·杜帕斯。对他的车进行搜查后，发现了两个自制的巴拉克拉法帽、胶带、避孕套、手铐、塑料布和一把铲子。还有三把刀，其中一把沾有露西·伊恩兹的血迹。他的衣服上也有她的血迹。杜帕斯在联系律师之前不愿与警方交谈。在此之后，除了“无可奉告”之外，他没有对调查人员说任何话。检察官处于一个困难的境地。
There was no doubt about what Dupasse had intended to do to Lucy, yet the evidence didn't support an attempted rape charge. Peter ultimately pleaded guilty to unlawful imprisonment in order to have the more serious charges of kidnapping, assault with a weapon, and in decent assault dropped. Sentencing took place in November 1994. Jupas' criminal history was referred to in court as breathtaking. His most recent attack was deemed calculated. He had watched and waited until Lucy was separated from her friends, concealed his identity, and used a weapon with other equipment at hand. The judge accepted that the crime was sexually
毫无疑问杜帕斯对露西意图不轨，但证据不足以支持强奸未遂的指控。彼得最终承认了非法监禁罪，以换取撤销绑架、持械袭击和猥亵罪等更严重的指控。判决于1994年11月进行。杜帕斯的犯罪记录在法庭上被称为“令人震惊”。他最近的袭击被认为是经过计算的。他观察并等待露西与朋友分开，隐藏了自己的身份，并使用了武器和其他现成的设备。法官接受了该犯罪具有性
motivated, but clarified. I must punish you only for the offense charged, and not for what I think you were going to do, but did not. Highlighting that the victim was held captive for only a few minutes and was voluntarily released, the judge told Jupas. You acted in such a manner to give rise to at least the hope and perhaps the prospect that realization of the significance of what you are about to do activated your conscience. I cannot therefore preclude' hints of conscience. Jupas was sentenced to three years and a nine months imprisonment. This was a major blow to Victoria Police. A year prior, the state government had passed a controversial law to protect the community
动机的说法，但澄清道：“我必须仅因被指控的罪行惩罚你，而不是因为我认为你打算做但未做的事情。”法官强调受害者仅被囚禁了几分钟并被自愿释放，对杜帕斯说：“你的行为至少引起了希望，甚至可能是意识到你即将做的事情的严重性而激活了你的良知。因此，我不能排除你存在良知的迹象。”杜帕斯被判处三年零九个月监禁。这对维多利亚州警方是一个重大打击。一年前，州政府通过了一项有争议的法律来保护社区
from serial sex offenders. It enabled courts to sentence criminals to indefinite jail terms. However, the law could only be activated in cases where the defendant had committed a so-called serious offense. Unlawful imprisonment fell short as it was considered too minor. A group of parents contacted the parole board urging that Peter Dupasse never be released. Yet, by now, he'd mastered the legal system. Realising that denying his crimes jeopardized his chance of parole, he started admitting to them and seemingly accepting treatment. One council are remained skeptical of Jupas, writing,
免受连环性犯罪者的侵害。它使法院能够判处罪犯无限期监禁。然而，该法律只能在被告犯有所谓“严重罪行”的情况下激活。非法监禁因被认为太轻而未达标准。一群家长联系了假释委员会，敦促永远不要释放彼得·杜帕斯。然而，此时他已经精通法律体系。意识到否认罪行会危及他假释的机会，他开始承认罪行并似乎接受治疗。一位顾问对杜帕斯仍持怀疑态度，写道：
through long-term association with various professionals, he has learnt to manipulate any individual who has endeavoured to challenge his offending behaviour, by the way of saying the right things and behaving in a convincing manner in a supervised environment. Despite this and other scathing reports, police were powerless to stop Peter Dupasse. He was granted release again in September 1996 at age 43 after serving his two-year minimum sentence. By this point, he'd spent 17 of his last 20 years in jail for sexual offences. His wife Grace conceded their marriage was over, telling the Sunday herald son newspaper. Peter was two people living inside one shell. One was kind and gentle. The other was pure
“通过与各种专业人士的长期接触，他学会了操纵任何试图挑战他犯罪行为的人，通过在受监管的环境中说正确的话和表现出令人信服的行为。”尽管有这些和其他严厉的报告，警方也无力阻止彼得·杜帕斯。他在1996年9月年满43岁时再次获准释放，此前他服完了两年的最低刑期。到此时，他在过去20年里有17年因性犯罪在监狱中度过。他的妻子格蕾丝承认他们的婚姻已经结束，告诉《星期日先驱太阳报》。彼得是住在同一个躯壳里的两个人。一个是善良温柔的。另一个是纯粹的
evil. Dupasse's parents no longer supported him and had moved into state. He resettled in Melbourne's North, when no one knew of his past. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. When Peter Dupasse was linked to psychotherapists Nicole Patterson through calls made from his home, investigators were certain they had found Nicole's killer. Given his history, it seemed Dupasse had escalated just as police predicted.
邪恶。杜帕斯的父母不再支持他，并搬到了州外。他在墨尔本北部重新定居，那里没人知道他的过去。案件档案很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。当彼得·杜帕斯通过从家中打出的电话与心理治疗师妮可·帕特森联系起来时，调查人员确信他们找到了妮可的杀手。鉴于他的历史，杜帕斯似乎正如警方预测的那样升级了。
They moved quickly and attracted Dupasse to a hotel where they found him playing a slot machine in the gaming room. A glint of surprise appeared on his face when police encircled him. A search of Dupas' clothing revealed nothing of significance, though officers did notice two curved scratches on his left cheek. They looked recent and were the type caused by fingernails. Dupas denied everything. He said he didn't know Nicole Patterson and had never been to Harperstreed in Northcut. When asked about the scratches on his face, Dupas, who was now a self-employed woodworker,
他们迅速行动，将杜帕斯引诱到一家酒店，发现他正在游戏室玩老虎机。当警察包围他时，他脸上闪过一丝惊讶。对杜帕斯衣服的搜查没有发现任何重要物品，但警官确实注意到他左脸颊上有两道弯曲的抓痕。它们看起来很新，是那种由指甲造成的抓痕。杜帕斯否认了一切。他说他不认识妮可·帕特森，也从未去过北科特的哈珀街。当被问及脸上的抓痕时，现在是自雇木工的杜帕斯，
claimed a piece of wood had flung up while he was using a lathe machine tool in his workshop garage. Before participating in any further interviews, Dupasse called his solicitor and a priestied mat while incarcerated. He then resorted to a previous tactic of responding to war questions put to him with no comment. A search of Dupasse's Pasco Vale home was underway. A note attached to the site of his fridge featured the name Harry and the phone number belonging to Indian student Harbourgan Kali that was provided to Nicole Patterson by the mysterious
声称他在车库工作室使用车床工具时，一块木头飞了起来。在参加任何进一步的采访之前，杜帕斯打电话给他的律师和一位在服刑期间认识的牧师。然后，他采取了之前的策略，对向他提出的所有问题都回答“无可奉告”。对杜帕斯位于帕斯科维尔的家的搜查正在进行中。冰箱侧面贴着的一张纸条上写着“哈里”的名字和属于印度学生哈尔布甘·卡利的电话号码，该号码是神秘的“马尔科姆”提供给妮可·帕特森的。
Malcolm. Also found was a copy of a Harold Sun newspaper dated several days after Nicole Patterson's murder. The front page featured an article on the case titled Psycho Knife Killo. Someone had slashed the accompanying image of Nicole's face. Examination of Dupasse's workshop failed to uncover the lathe he claimed caused the scratches on his face. A bag inside his wheelie bin contained torn-up pieces of newspaper. They had come from the advertising section of the Northcut leader, where Nicole Patterson had advertised her therapy services.
还发现了一份日期为妮可·帕特森谋杀案发生几天后的《先驱太阳报》。头版刊登了一篇关于此案的文章，标题为“心理变态刀手”。有人划破了随附的妮可脸部照片。对杜帕斯工作室的检查未能发现他声称导致脸上抓痕的车床。他轮式垃圾桶内的一个袋子里装有撕碎的报纸碎片。它们来自《北科特领袖报》的广告版面，妮可·帕特森曾在那里刊登过她的治疗服务广告。
Someone had written Nicole's home address on the page, along with the words Niki, North Cat, Malcolm, 9am, and Mo, believed to be shortened for morning. The other side contained Nicole's home phone and mobile numbers. A handwriting expert concluded that this information was scrawled by Peter Dupasse. Dupasse ultimately admitted to making these notes and placing Nicole's to Nicole Patterson's home. He said he'd found her right in the paper and set up an appointment on the day of her murder to address his gambling and relationship problems. Dupasse confessed to providing Nicole with a fake name and number in panic because he didn't
有人在页面上写下了妮可的家庭住址，以及“妮基、北科特、马尔科姆、上午9点和Mo”（被认为是早晨的缩写）等字样。另一面包含妮可的家庭电话和手机号码。一位笔迹专家得出结论，这些信息是彼得·杜帕斯潦草写下的。杜帕斯最终承认写了这些笔记并前往妮可·帕特森的家。他说他在报纸上看到了她的广告，并在她被谋杀的那天预约了时间，以解决他的赌博和人际关系问题。杜帕斯承认因恐慌而向妮可提供了假名和假号码，因为他不想
want his girlfriend to know he was seeking therapy. He claimed that he had second thoughts about the session and rang to cancel. Nicole apparently understood and said, if you need to contact me, contact me. Dupasse insisted that he'd spent the morning doing work, errands and domestic chores, and didn't go near Nicole's home at all. Inside his work shed on the bottom shelf of a cupboard, police found a jacket bundled up with other clothing. Inside one of its pockets was a balaclava. The jacket was also splattered with blood. Testing revealed the blood belonged to both Nicole Patterson and Peter Dupasse.
让女朋友知道他在寻求治疗。他声称他对这次会面有了顾虑，并打电话取消了。妮可显然理解并说：“如果你需要联系我，请联系我。”杜帕斯坚称他那天早上一直在做工作、跑腿和家务，根本没有靠近妮可的家。在他的工作棚里，在橱柜的底层架子上，警方发现了一件与其他衣服捆在一起的夹克。其中一个口袋里有一顶巴拉克拉法帽。夹克上也溅满了血迹。检测显示血迹属于妮可·帕特森和彼得·杜帕斯两人。
CCTV footage was obtained from a petrol station that Dupasse had visited shortly before Nicole was killed, confirming he'd been wearing the jacket. Jupas admitted the jacket was his and that he'd worn it the morning Nicole was killed, but denied knowing how her blood got on it. The circumstantial evidence was damning, and as a result, Peter Dupasse was formally charged with Nicole Paterson's murder. He pleaded not guilty and faced trial in August 2000. Homicide detectives had worked diligently to ensure their case was solid. The defense team had limited options, and resorted to insinuating that evidence against their client was planted
警方从杜帕斯在妮可被杀前不久访问过的一家加油站获得了闭路电视录像，证实他当时穿着那件夹克。杜帕斯承认夹克是他的，并且在妮可被杀的那天早上穿过它，但否认知道她的血迹是如何沾上去的。间接证据确凿，因此，彼得·杜帕斯被正式指控谋杀妮可·帕特森。他不认罪，并于2000年8月受审。凶杀案侦探们努力工作以确保他们的案件证据确凿。辩护团队的选择有限，只能暗示针对他们客户的证据是
by police. They implied that a detective had taken a vial of Nicole Paterson's blood to Jupiter's home and adripped the liquid on his jacket, acclaimed the police denied. A soft spoken Jupiter passed took the stand where he appeared nervous. When asked if he killed Nicole, jupas asserted, no, I did not. He intimated that the evidence against him was just bad luck. The prosecution remarked, and it's just bad luck too, isn't it, that the jacket you say you were probably wearing on that morning happens to have the deceased's blood on it?
由警方栽赃的。他们暗示一名侦探拿了一小瓶妮可·帕特森的血到杜帕斯的家，并将液体滴在他的夹克上，警方否认了这一说法。说话轻声细语的杜帕斯走上证人席，看起来很紧张。当被问及是否杀害了妮可时，杜帕斯断言：“不，我没有。”他暗示针对他的证据只是运气不好。检方反驳道：“这也是运气不好，对吧？你声称那天早上可能穿的夹克恰好有死者的血迹？”
Dupasse replied, for me it is, yes. A smile appeared on his face as he accused police of setting him up. Everything else Dupasse admitted to, from hindering identification efforts to destroying evidence, he insisted wasn't done with bad intent. The prosecution worked to prove the impossibility of police planting evidence. Then they had one final question for Dupas.
杜帕斯回答：“对我来说是这样，是的。”当他指责警方陷害他时，他脸上露出了笑容。杜帕斯承认的其他一切，从阻碍身份识别工作到销毁证据，他都坚称不是出于恶意。检方努力证明警方栽赃证据是不可能的。然后，他们对杜帕斯提出了最后一个问题。
Where have you hidden your trophies, the breasts you cut off the deceased, her driver's license and her purse? Dupasse replied, I don't know what you're talking about. It took a jury less than three hours to find Peter Dupasse guilty for Nicole Paterson's murder. The judge told him, you regarded Nicole Paterson as murder. The judge told him, You regarded Nicole Paterson as nothing more than prey to being trapped and killed. Her life, youth and personal qualities assumed importance in your mind only by reason of
“你把你的战利品藏在哪里了？你从死者身上割下的乳房、她的驾照和钱包？”杜帕斯回答：“我不知道你在说什么。”陪审团用了不到三个小时就裁定彼得·杜帕斯谋杀妮可·帕特森罪名成立。法官告诉他：“你将妮可·帕特森视为猎物，只为了被诱捕和杀害。她的生命、青春和个人品质在你的脑海中变得重要，仅仅是因为
the sense of satisfaction and power which you experienced in taking them from her. You carried out your crime with remorseless deliberation and after careful manipulation of the situation, in full understanding of the significance of your actions. You are now 47 years with a deeply entrenched desire to engage in sexually violent behavior. You have not responded in anything remotely approaching an appropriate fashion to sentences of imprisonment, psychiatric treatment, or community supervision. Realistically considered, the prospects of your eventual rehabilitation must be regarded as close to hopeless that they can be effectively discounted.
你从剥夺她这些东西中体验到的满足感和权力感。你怀着冷酷的蓄意，在对情况进行精心操纵后，在完全理解自己行为意义的情况下实施了犯罪。你现在47岁，有着根深蒂固的进行性暴力行为的欲望。你对监禁、精神治疗或社区监管的判决没有做出任何接近适当的反应。现实地考虑，你最终康复的前景必须被视为几乎毫无希望，以至于可以有效地忽略不计。”
Peter Dupasse was sentenced to life imprisonment without the possibility of parole. Nicole's loved ones had mixed reactions. Her boyfriend wanted Dupasse dead. Nicole's father was just grateful the chapter was closed, while her mother said. It helps to know he's not going to be out there doing it again. If he were to walk free, he would kill again. Victoria police were elated that after 30 years of hurting women, Peter Dupasse would finally spend the rest of his natural life behind bars.
彼得·杜帕斯被判处终身监禁，不得假释。妮可的亲人反应不一。她的男朋友希望杜帕斯死。妮可的父亲只是感激这一篇章终于结束了，而她的母亲说：“知道他不会再出去做这种事，这很有帮助。如果他重获自由，他会再次杀人。”维多利亚州警方感到欣喜，在伤害女性30年后，彼得·杜帕斯终于将在铁窗后度过他余下的自然生命。
But their work wasn't over yet. They believed he held many more dark secrets. The first centered around the unsolved murder of Margaret Ma in 1997. Her mutilated remains were found on the side of an industrial backroad in Summerton. Following Nicole Paterson's murder, links were drawn back to Margaret. Notably, both women had won or both of their breasts removed. The now-emprisoned Peter Dupasse was interviewed about Margaret Mars' murder. He began shaking.
但他们的工作还没有结束。他们相信他隐藏了更多黑暗的秘密。第一个围绕着1997年玛格丽特·马的未解谋杀案。她被肢解的遗体在萨默顿的一条工业后路边被发现。在妮可·帕特森被谋杀后，人们将线索追溯到了玛格丽特身上。值得注意的是，两名女性都被切除了乳房。现已入狱的彼得·杜帕斯就玛格丽特·马的谋杀案接受了采访。他开始颤抖。
Detectives asked if he knew Margaret, or if he had attended the same supermarket she had on the night of her murder. They also asked if he owned any gloves, in reference to the single black woolen glove recovered at the crime scene. Dupasse reverted to answering all questions with no comment, though he did agree to have his mouth swabbed for DNA analysis. With technological advancements in forensic testing, the black love from the Mar case was reexamined. Margaret hadn't warned it. Biological mixture of at least two people were detected,
侦探们询问他是否认识玛格丽特，或者他是否在谋杀当晚去过她去过的同一家超市。他们还询问他是否拥有任何手套，以指代在犯罪现场发现的一只黑色羊毛手套。杜帕斯又回到了对所有问题都回答“无可奉告”的状态，尽管他同意采集口腔拭子进行DNA分析。随着法医检测技术的进步，马案中的黑色手套被重新检查。玛格丽特并没有戴过它。检测到了至少两个人的生物混合物，
but because they were mixed, it was impossible to confirm who wore the glove at the time of the murder. One of the samples was from a random person police couldn't ascertain. The other was consistent with Peter Dupasse. The clothing Margaret had worn at the time of her murder was also re-examined. Her tops had been cut away with sharp, smooth-bladed scissors, similar to how Nicole Patterson's had been removed. Examination of Dupasse's phone records revealed that at the time of Margaret's murder, he had made multiple calls to phone sex lines. One was traced to Irene Langley.
但由于它们是混合的，无法确认谋杀时是谁戴着这只手套。其中一个样本来自警方无法确定的随机人员。另一个与彼得·杜帕斯一致。玛格丽特在谋杀时所穿的衣服也经过了重新检查。她的上衣是用锋利、平滑的剪刀剪开的，类似于妮可·帕特森衣服被移除的方式。对杜帕斯电话记录的检查显示，在玛格丽特被谋杀时，他曾多次拨打色情电话。其中一个被追踪到艾琳·兰利。
She never forgot the disturbing call she received around October 1997. She told detectives how the male caller detailed hurting a woman with a knife. Most significantly, he referred to cutting off one of her breasts. A second attempted interviewing Dupasse went nowhere. He remained as tight-lipped as ever. Despite this, he was charged with the murder of Margaret Ma. At trial in July 2004, the prosecution relied on the treatment of Margaret's body in relation to Nicole Patterson.
她从未忘记1997年10月左右接到的那个令人不安的电话。她告诉侦探，那名男性来电者详细描述了如何用刀伤害一名女性。最重要的是，他提到了割掉她的一侧乳房。第二次试图采访杜帕斯（Dupasse）毫无进展。他依然守口如瓶。尽管如此，他还是被指控谋杀了玛格丽特·马（Margaret Ma）。在2004年7月的审判中，检方依赖于玛格丽特尸体处理方式与妮可·帕特森（Nicole Patterson）案的关联。
Quote, We say the cutting of the breasts is so unique as to effectively be a signature, a stamp. In fact, after examining almost 4,000 homicides throughout Australia between 1989 and 2000, the only other case involving breast mutilation was that of Nicole Patterson. While Peter GiuPas didn't take the stand on this occasion, 51 other witnesses did. By the end of proceedings, the jury reached a guilty verdict. The Judge told Jupas, After you murdered Margaret Ma, you left her by the side of the road in a desolate place
引用如下：“我们认为，割掉乳房的行为非常独特，实际上是一种签名，一种印记。事实上，在检查了1989年至2000年间澳大利亚发生的近4000起凶杀案后，唯一涉及乳房残害的案件就是妮可·帕特森案。”虽然彼得·杜帕斯这次没有出庭作证，但其他51名证人出庭了。诉讼结束时，陪审团作出了有罪判决。法官对杜帕斯说：“在你谋杀玛格丽特·马之后，你把她留在了荒凉之地的路边，
as a disgusting display of loathing for the deceased and contempt for her dignity. Not contempt with what you had done to her in life, you robbed her of her dignity in death. Sentencing Jupas would have no practical effect as it was already serving life without parole. Still, the judge insisted that punishing him for Margaret's murder was not futile. By doing so, it vindicated Margaret's rights and those left behind to struggle with the grief and trauma of her murder. For that, Peter Dupasse was handed another life sentence without the possibility of parole. Margaret's loved ones thanked Victoria Police for their efforts to bring her killer justice.
这是对死者令人作呕的厌恶表现，也是对她尊严的蔑视。不仅是对你生前对她所做之事的蔑视，你还剥夺了她死后的尊严。”判处杜帕斯刑罚已无实际意义，因为他已经在服无假释的终身监禁。尽管如此，法官坚持认为惩罚他谋杀玛格丽特并非徒劳。这样做是为了维护玛格丽特的权利，以及那些留下来与谋杀带来的悲伤和创伤作斗争的人们的权利。为此，彼得·杜帕斯又被判处了一项不得假释的终身监禁。玛格丽特的亲人感谢维多利亚州警方为将凶手绳之以法所做的努力。
Her brother remarked, Margaret lived her life the way she chose, and no one had the right to take that life from her. Members of Nicole Paterson's family attended the trial as a show of support to Margaret's loved ones. Outside court, Nicole's sister said, It's such a rare evil that comes into this world that's destroyed these women and our lives.
她的兄弟评论道：“玛格丽特选择了她自己的生活方式，没有人有权夺走她的生命。”妮可·帕特森家人的成员出席了庭审，以示对玛格丽特亲人的支持。在法庭外，妮可的姐姐说：“这种罕见的邪恶降临到这个世界上，摧毁了这些女性和我们的生活。”
We're just praying that this man is accountable for everything he has done. By the time Peter Dupasse was handed his second life sentence in 2004, police was certain he was also responsible for Messina Halvaga's 1997 murder. Dupasse's grandfather was buried in Forknessemetry, just 128 meters west of where Messina's grandmother lay. Nine women had since come forward to identify Jupas as the men who had harassed them in the cemetery before Messina was struck. One described him as having a unique tear in the right pocket region of his jacket, which matched a blemish on the jacket Jupasse war when he killed Nicole Patterson. He'd also been seen wearing gold-framed eye glasses and blue tradesmen overalls.
“我们只是祈祷这个人能为他所做的一切负责。”到2004年彼得·杜帕斯被判处第二次终身监禁时，警方确信他还应对1997年梅西娜·哈尔瓦加（Messina Halvaga）的谋杀案负责。杜帕斯的祖父被安葬在福克纳公墓（Fawkner Cemetery），距离梅西娜祖母的安息地仅128米。此后，有九名女性站出来指认杜帕斯就是梅西娜遇害前在公墓骚扰她们的人。其中一人描述他夹克右口袋区域有一个独特的撕裂口，这与杜帕斯杀害妮可·帕特森时所穿夹克上的瑕疵相吻合。他还被看到戴着金框眼镜，穿着蓝色工装裤。
Two items that Dupasse was known to wear at the time. In the immediate aftermath of Mercenus Murder, it was discovered that Dupasse had visited a salon to have his hair cut and died, as though to prevent him from being matched to the photofid of the cemetery stalker. Messina's upper clothing had become bunched up and tangled in her arms. Investigators believed this had prevented Jupas from mutilating her like he had his other victims. He couldn't risk the time it would take to remove it and adopted to flee. Questioning Dupasse about Messinus murder was characteristically futile,
这是杜帕斯当时众所周知的两件物品。在梅西娜谋杀案发生后不久，人们发现杜帕斯去了一家沙龙剪发并染发，似乎是为了防止自己被认出是公墓跟踪狂的照片。梅西娜的上衣被卷起并缠绕在她的手臂上。调查人员认为，这阻止了杜帕斯像对待其他受害者那样残害她。他无法冒着移除衣服所需的时间风险，选择了逃跑。询问杜帕斯关于梅西娜谋杀案的情况一如既往地徒劳，
as he immediately resorted to his typical no-comment answers. Detectives contacted inmates who were in prison with Peter Dupas, hoping he might have said something incriminating while on the inside. One prisoner, a former high-profile solicitor named Andrew Fraser, was serving time for his role in the importation and trafficking of the commercial quantity of cocaine. Given Fraser's previous employment, detectives assumed he'd refuse working with them and encouraged Dupas to keep quiet. To their surprise, Fraser told detectives,
因为他立即诉诸他典型的“无可奉告”式回答。侦探们联系了与彼得·杜帕斯一起服刑的囚犯，希望他能在狱中说出一些有罪的供词。一名囚犯，前知名律师安德鲁·弗雷泽（Andrew Fraser），因参与进口和贩运大量可卡因而正在服刑。鉴于弗雷泽以前的职业，侦探们认为他会拒绝与他们合作，并鼓励杜帕斯保持沉默。令他们惊讶的是，弗雷泽告诉侦探：
You had better come and see me. Andrew Fraser provided a full statement in which he detailed his relationship with Peter Dupas. The pair were in protective custody together and were both tasked on guard and duties. They also interacted while watching the prison television. Fraser found Dupas to be quiet, socially inept, suspicious, and introspective. He was reluctant to talk, but when he did, he spoke in disjointed short sentences interspersed by long breaks, as though he censored himself to avoid saying anything he'd regret. Fraser also witnessed a Dupas breaking out in mysterious full-body shakes, sweat, and tears.
“你们最好过来见我。”安德鲁·弗雷泽提供了一份完整的陈述，详细说明了他与彼得·杜帕斯的关系。两人一起被关在保护性拘留所，并被指派执行守卫任务。他们在观看监狱电视时也有互动。弗雷泽发现杜帕斯安静、社交笨拙、多疑且内省。他不愿交谈，但当他开口时，他用断断续续的短句说话，中间夹杂着长时间的停顿，仿佛他在自我审查以避免说出任何他会后悔的话。弗雷泽还目睹了杜帕斯全身出现神秘的颤抖、出汗和流泪。
In time, Dupas opened up to Fraser as much as he thought the man was capable of. Fraser described Dupas as, the most dangerous and unpredictable person I have ever met. Fraser recalled a group conversation involving himself, Dupasse, and a convicted rapist and a murderer named Raymond Edmonds, better known as Mr. Stinky. Edmonds' crimes are covered in episode 131 of Case File. Edmonds was 20 years into his prison sentence and was telling the others that he had committed a bad offense, regretted it, and was paying the heavy price.
随着时间的推移，杜帕斯向弗雷泽敞开了心扉，达到了他认为此人所能达到的程度。弗雷泽将杜帕斯描述为“我见过的最危险、最不可预测的人”。弗雷泽回忆起一次小组谈话，参与者包括他自己、杜帕斯，以及一名被定罪的强奸犯和杀人犯雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹（Raymond Edmonds），也就是众所周知的“臭味先生”（Mr. Stinky）。埃德蒙兹的罪行在《案件档案》（Case File）第131集中有介绍。埃德蒙兹已经服刑20年，当时正在告诉其他人他犯下了一个严重的罪行，对此感到后悔，并正在付出沉重的代价。
He turned to Dupas and asked, what about you Pete? Dupas went quiet before admitting offhandedly to killing Nicole Patterson. What's done is done, and I have to wear it," he said. One occasion, Andrew Fraser was working in the garden with the Dupasse when he uncovered a makeshift a knife in the dirt. He showed it to Dupasse, who examined it, and began to sweat. A strange expression appeared on his face before he uttered the word Messina. Another time, Fraser observed an inmate approach to pass and say,
他转向杜帕斯问道：“那你呢，皮特？”杜帕斯沉默了一会儿，然后漫不经心地承认杀害了妮可·帕特森。“事情已经发生了，我必须承担，”他说。有一次，安德鲁·弗雷泽和杜帕斯在花园里工作时，在泥土中发现了一把临时制作的刀。他把它拿给杜帕斯看，杜帕斯检查了一下，开始出汗。他的脸上出现了一种奇怪的表情，然后吐出了“梅西娜”这个词。另一次，弗雷泽观察到一名囚犯走近杜帕斯并说：
you are Peter Dupas. When Dupas confirmed, the man revealed that he was Messina Havagas' cousin. He called Dupas an animal and threatened to kill him when he got the chance. Shaken, Jupas said to Andrew Fraser. How does that count no I did it? When Jupas was charged with Margaret Mars murder, he told Fraser he thought they might charge him with Messina's murder as well. Jupas stressed that no one witnessed the attack. He also remarked that he hadn't left any forensic set forkness symmetry. It was true that Messinus killer hadn't left behind any forensic evidence, but that information
“你是彼得·杜帕斯。”当杜帕斯确认后，那个人透露他是梅西娜·哈尔瓦加的表亲。他称杜帕斯为畜生，并威胁说有机会就杀了他。杜帕斯感到震惊，对安德鲁·弗雷泽说：“他们怎么知道是我干的？”当杜帕斯被指控谋杀玛格丽特·马时，他告诉弗雷泽，他认为他们可能也会指控他谋杀梅西娜。杜帕斯强调没有人目击了那次袭击。他还评论说，他在福克纳公墓没有留下任何法医证据。梅西娜的凶手确实没有留下任何法医证据，但那个信息
wasn't public at the time. Andrew Fraser Fraser quote, It was clear to me that there was only one way Peter would have known that fact, and that is, he is the killer. Andrew Fraser's statement came with a degree of criticism. There was a million dollar reward on offer in Messina Halvaga's case, and Fraser was given an undisclosed percentage of it. Yet, homicide detectives stressed that this reward was offered months before Fraser rented the case, and that if he were motivated by money, he would have reached out to them,
在当时并不是公开的。安德鲁·弗雷泽引用道：“我很清楚，彼得只有一种方式知道那个事实，那就是，他就是凶手。”安德鲁·弗雷泽的陈述受到了一定程度的批评。梅西娜·哈尔瓦加案悬赏一百万美元，弗雷泽获得了其中未公开的百分比。然而，凶杀案侦探强调，这笔赏金是在弗雷泽介入案件前几个月提供的，如果他是为了钱，他早就联系他们了，
not the other way around. Following Fraser's statement, detectives questioned Dupas merely as a matter of procedure, though they knew he was unlikely to concede anything. As expected, he kept a dead pen expression and responded no comment to everything. Dupas was informed that a witness had provided a statement as certain he had confessed to Messina how Vargas' murder. For the first time in all their encounters with Dupas, detectives felt he was genuinely shocked. No comment, he responded.
而不是反过来。在弗雷泽发表声明后，侦探们仅按程序询问了杜帕斯，尽管他们知道他不太可能承认任何事情。正如预期的那样，他保持着死板的表情，对所有问题都回答“无可奉告”。杜帕斯被告知，一名证人提供了陈述，确认他承认了梅西娜·哈尔瓦加的谋杀案。在他们与杜帕斯的所有接触中，侦探们第一次感到他真的震惊了。“无可奉告，”他回答道。
He was then charged with Messina's murder. His legal team tried to argue that he had become so infamous that a fair trial was impossible. The judge disagreed and the trial went ahead in 2007. The defense attempted to pin the crime on Messina's fiance, Angelogor Gewski, though their efforts were in vain. Peter Dupasse was ultimately found guilty for Messina help Argus's murder. The judge told Dupasse, Messina's last actions were typical of her, a fine young woman in a place of peace and beauty,
随后他被指控谋杀梅西娜。他的法律团队试图辩称他已经变得臭名昭著，以至于不可能进行公平的审判。法官不同意，审判于2007年继续进行。辩方试图将罪行归咎于梅西娜的未婚夫安杰洛·戈尔格夫斯基（Angelo Gorgievski），但他们的努力是徒劳的。彼得·杜帕斯最终被判谋杀梅西娜·哈尔瓦加罪名成立。法官告诉杜帕斯：“梅西娜最后的行为是她典型的表现，一个美好的年轻女性，在一个和平与美丽的地方，
thinking not of herself but of others, devoted, considerate and good. Then you struck. Just as Messina's presence at the cemetery was typical of her goodness, your presence at the cemetery was typical of your evil. Cunning, predatory and homicidal. She had no chance against your strength, your knife, and your hate. Then, with your bloody knife, you vanished from the scene. But it was your cunning that was to bring you undone. For you left to no forensics at
想到的不是自己而是他人，忠诚、体贴且善良。然后你袭击了她。正如梅西娜在公墓的存在是她善良的典型，你在公墓的存在也是你邪恶的典型。狡猾、掠夺性和杀人成性。她在你的力量、你的刀和你的仇恨面前毫无机会。然后，带着你沾满鲜血的刀，你从现场消失了。但正是你的狡猾让你走向了毁灭。因为你在福克纳没有留下任何法医证据，
Faulkner, words which would come back to haunt you. You have no prospects of rehabilitation, none. You do not suffer from any mental illness. Rather, you are a psychopath, motivated by a deeply entrenched, perverted and sadistic hatred of women. A complete contempt for them, and they're right to live. Peter Dupasse was handed his third life sentence. He appealed, but failed. In 2012, he was granted a retrial for Messina Halvaga's murder, only to be found to guilty again. But his story wasn't over.
这些话最终会回来困扰你。你没有任何康复的前景，一点也没有。你没有患任何精神疾病。相反，你是一个精神病态者，被一种根深蒂固、变态和虐待狂般的仇恨女性的心理所驱动。对她们以及她们生存的权利完全蔑视。”彼得·杜帕斯被判处了第三次终身监禁。他上诉，但失败了。2012年，他获准就梅西娜·哈尔瓦加的谋杀案进行重审，结果再次被判有罪。但他的故事还没有结束。
Authorities believed a Jupas held the answers to more unsolved violent acts, sexual assaults, and murders. In his statement to detectives, prison informant Andrew Fraser wrote of an instance where Dupasse was talking about the murders being pinned on him, and said, I reckon I'm going to end up wearing the old sheeler down to. It seemed Dupasse was referring to 95-year-old Kathleen Downs. Kathleen was stabbed three times and her throat was slit while she lay in bed in a Brunswick nursing home in December 1997, a month after Messina Halvagas was killed.
当局认为杜帕斯掌握着更多未破的暴力行为、性侵犯和谋杀案的答案。在给侦探的陈述中，监狱线人安德鲁·弗雷泽写道，有一次杜帕斯在谈论那些被归咎于他的谋杀案时说：“我想我最终也会背上那个老太婆的案子。”似乎杜帕斯指的是95岁的凯瑟琳·唐斯（Kathleen Downs）。1997年12月，在梅西娜·哈尔瓦加被杀一个月后，凯瑟琳在不伦瑞克的一家疗养院床上被刺三刀并割喉。
Kathleen described as a dear lady with a wonderful nature was considered the matriarch of the nursing home. Evidence indicated that her killer had broken into the building in the early hours between routine checks of the residents. Records showed that Peter Dupasse was home when two calls were made to Kathleen's nursing home. One was made in the month before, the other occurred the morning of. Dupasse was questioned about Kathleen's murder in 2013, but he denied any involvement. He assured Andrew Fraser, they will never get me for that.
凯瑟琳被描述为一位性格极好的亲切女士，被认为是疗养院的大家长。证据表明，凶手在居民例行检查之间的凌晨闯入了大楼。记录显示，当有人给凯瑟琳的疗养院打两个电话时，彼得·杜帕斯都在家。一个是在前一个月打的，另一个发生在当天早上。杜帕斯在2013年因凯瑟琳的谋杀案受到讯问，但他否认了任何参与。他向安德鲁·弗雷泽保证：“他们永远不会因为那个抓住我。”
Yet, Dupasse was ultimately charged with Kathleen's murder and set to go to trial in 2019. By this stage, star witness Andrew Fraser was suffering from spinal cancer and was too unwell to give evidence and withstand cross-examination. As a result, the trial was discontinued. The presiding judge asserted that the decision didn't constitute an acquittal, and that Jupas could be re-indicted on the murder charge at any time. Kathleen Downs' family were disappointed, but understanding and grateful to the police and prosecutors's efforts. Peter Dupasse is also a suspect in the murders of 48-year-old Helen McMahon and 31-year-old
然而，杜帕斯最终还是被指控谋杀凯瑟琳，并定于2019年受审。到这个阶段，明星证人安德鲁·弗雷泽患有脊柱癌，身体状况太差，无法提供证据并经受交叉询问。因此，审判中止了。主审法官断言，该决定并不构成无罪释放，杜帕斯随时可能因谋杀指控被重新起诉。凯瑟琳·唐斯的家人感到失望，但表示理解，并感谢警察和检察官的努力。彼得·杜帕斯也是48岁的海伦·麦克马洪（Helen McMahon）和31岁的
Renita Brunton. The specifics of Helen's murder are withheld by police, though they've established she was violently attacked while some baking in the seaside town of Rai. Helen was killed 16 days before Dupasse raped Hannah Gadsden on a beach 4 kilometres away in Blair Gowry. He denied involvement in Helen McMahon's murder and it was initially thought that he could and have done it as he was technically meant to be imprisoned during this time. Years later, it emerged that he was actually on pre-release the day Helen was targeted. Police believe Helen McMahon could be Jupiter's first murder victim. In November 1993, Reneta Brunton was stabbed to 106 times in a clothing store she operated in
雷妮塔·布伦顿（Renita Brunton）谋杀案的嫌疑人。海伦谋杀案的具体细节被警方隐瞒，尽管他们已经确定她在海滨小镇莱伊（Rye）烘焙时遭到暴力袭击。海伦在杜帕斯于4公里外的布莱尔高里（Blairgowrie）海滩强奸汉娜·加兹登（Hannah Gadsden）前16天被杀。他否认参与海伦·麦克马洪的谋杀案，最初人们认为他不可能做到，因为他当时在技术上应该在服刑。多年后，事实证明他在海伦遇害那天实际上处于预释放状态。警方认为海伦·麦克马洪可能是杜帕斯的第一个谋杀受害者。1993年11月，雷妮塔·布伦顿在她经营的一家服装店被刺106刀，
Sunbury. Reneta had been holding informal counseling sessions out the back of her business, and told friends she was meeting a man with a violent sexual history that day. Most of her wounds sent it around her chest. At the time, Peter Dupasse lived less than an hour's drive away in Woodent, where Reneda also resided. He has been unhelpful when inquired about Reneda's death. Questioning Peter Dupasse is described as frustrating.
位于森伯里（Sunbury）。雷妮塔一直在她的生意后方进行非正式的咨询会议，并告诉朋友她那天要见一个有暴力性史的男人。她的大部分伤口集中在胸部。当时，彼得·杜帕斯住在不到一小时车程的伍登德（Woodend），雷妮塔也住在那里。当被问及雷妮塔的死时，他一直不予配合。询问彼得·杜帕斯被描述为令人沮丧。
Even in the face of overwhelming evidence, he denies everything. He then breaks down, and just when it appears as though he is about to confess, he straightens up and denies everything again. According to one detective, getting a clear answer out of Peter Dupasse is like trying to open a locked door without a key. Following his guilty verdict for the murder of Nicole Patterson, Peter Jew Pass was asked by the judge. At a fundamental level as human beings, you present for us the awful, threatening, and unanswerable question. How did you come to be as you are?
即使面对压倒性的证据，他也否认一切。然后他崩溃了，就在他似乎要坦白的时候，他又挺直身子，再次否认一切。据一位侦探说，从彼得·杜帕斯口中得到一个明确的答案就像试图在没有钥匙的情况下打开一扇锁着的门。在妮可·帕特森谋杀案被判有罪后，法官问彼得·杜帕斯：“从根本上讲，作为人类，你向我们提出了一个可怕、具有威胁性且无法回答的问题。你是怎么变成现在这个样子的？”
Despite years of examination, experts still don't know what exactly motivated Peter Dupasse's crimes. Since his first attack as a 15-year-old, he has been unable or unwilling to provide any rational or honest explanation for his violent outbursts. He hasn't been diagnosed with any psychiatric disorders. The level of planning and rehearsal he undertook prior to committing his crimes is not normally associated with someone in sane.
尽管经过多年的检查，专家们仍然不知道究竟是什么促使了彼得·杜帕斯的犯罪。自他15岁时第一次袭击以来，他一直无法或不愿为他的暴力爆发提供任何合理或诚实的解释。他没有被诊断出患有任何精神疾病。他在犯罪前所进行的计划和排练程度通常与精神失常的人无关。
In calls to saxophone worker Irene Langley, Dupasse described an attack that reflected Margaret Mars murder, but referred to his victim as his mother, indicating there might be some issues there. There are also theories that Dupasse mutilated his victims because of insecurities he might have towards his own feminine-like breasts. In a report tended to the court during the Margaret Mar trial, a forensic psychologist concluded, Jupas attacked women to fulfill fantasies of conquest and control. For Jupas, the actual assault has not lived up to the fantasy which preceded the assault
在给性工作者艾琳·兰利（Irene Langley）的电话中，杜帕斯描述了一次反映玛格丽特·马谋杀案的袭击，但他称受害者为他的母亲，这表明那里可能存在一些问题。还有一种理论认为，杜帕斯残害受害者是因为他对自己女性化的乳房可能存在不安全感。在玛格丽特·马审判期间提交给法庭的一份报告中，一位法医心理学家总结道：“杜帕斯袭击女性是为了满足征服和控制的幻想。对于杜帕斯来说，实际的袭击并没有达到袭击前幻想的程度，
and is seen at times as disappointing. He does not feel reassured by either his performance or his victim's response and must find another victim, this time the right one. Thus his offensors become quite repetitive. Whatever the truth, Peter Dupasse was an unusual case for the criminal justice system. He was deemed too dangerous to be let out in public, yet too sane to be institutionalized for life. Criticism has been leveled against the judicial system for allowing jupasers' continual release, despite his escalating crimes and concerns expressed by authorities and the community.
有时被认为是令人失望的。他既没有从自己的表现中感到安心，也没有从受害者的反应中感到安心，必须寻找另一个受害者，这次是“正确”的一个。因此，他的犯罪变得相当重复。”无论真相如何，彼得·杜帕斯对刑事司法系统来说都是一个不寻常的案例。他被认为太危险而不能被释放到公众中，但又太清醒而不能被终身监禁。司法系统因允许杜帕斯不断获释而受到批评，尽管他的罪行不断升级，且当局和社区表达了担忧。
The President of Civil Liberties Group, Liberty Victoria, responded to this backlash by stating, neither imprisonment in itself nor parole itself, is going to stop everybody from committing a fancers. What's important to bear in mind is that a person has to be sentenced for the offense that they've committed, and that might mean that somebody gets a sentence that is proportionate for the crime, but it doesn't cure them of the dangerousness or the characteristic that makes them continue to offend. Peter Jupas will remain in prison until he dies.
公民自由组织“维多利亚自由”（Liberty Victoria）的主席回应了这种强烈反对，称：“无论是监禁本身还是假释本身，都无法阻止所有人犯罪。重要的是要记住，一个人必须为他们所犯的罪行受到判决，这可能意味着某人得到了与其罪行相称的判决，但这并不能治愈他们的危险性或导致他们继续犯罪的特征。”彼得·杜帕斯将一直被关在监狱里直到死亡。
In a letter he panned during his early days of offending, Jupas wrote, I feel that I'm not fully confident within myself and there is a possibility that I could re-offend I'll later date. I have no desire to be launched like a time bomb back into the community un-cured. Once again, I can't stress how important it is not only to me, but surely the whole community that this doesn't happen, and I'm given the opportunity to work on my problem. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在杜帕斯在犯罪初期写的一封信中，他写道：“我觉得我在内心深处并不完全自信，而且有可能在以后的日子里再次犯罪。我不想像定时炸弹一样在未治愈的情况下被扔回社区。再一次，我无法强调这不仅对我，而且对整个社区来说是多么重要，这种情况不会发生，并且我被给予机会去解决我的问题。”目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。